GOOD AFTERNOON.
I AM ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOSE MEDINA
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON HIGHER EDUCATION.
WHEN IT THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE TODAY?
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT THE
MATERIALS THAT ARE DISCUSSED AND
HANDED OUT TODAY.
CAN BE FOUND ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THIS
COMMITTEE HELD AN OVERSIGHT
HEARING. TO BEGIN THE
CONVERSATION OF HOW TO INCREASE.
FACULTY DIVERSITY SYSTEM WIDE
FOR ALL THREE PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SEGMENTS.
THE UC THE CSU AND THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM.
THIS HEARING IS PART OF THE
FOLLOW UP BUT WILL FOCUS SOLELY
ON THE UC SYSTEM.
RESEARCH AND STUDENTS TELL US
THAT A DIVERSE FACULTY
CONTRIBUTES TO THE SUCCESS.
OF A DIVERSE STUDENT BODY.
THE STUDENTS THAT ATTEND UC.
AND IMPROVES THE OVER ALL CAMPUS
CLIMATE [inaudible]
YET.
THERE CONTINUES TO BE A
SIGNIFICANT LACK.
OF DIVERSITY AMONG FACULTY AT
AMERICANS COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES.
BLACK AND LIKE THE YOU KNOW
FACULTY ARE PARTICULARLY UNDER
REPRESENTED.
AT RESEARCH UNIVERSITIES.
THE PERCENTAGE OF UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITY STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
HAS STEADILY INCREASE.
BUT DESPITE NUMEROUS EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE FACULTY DIVERSITY.
PROGRESS TO INCREASE THE
PROMOTION OF FEMALE AND UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITY FACULTY HAS
BEEN SLOW.
IN THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN BUDGET ACT.
THE ASSEMBLY SUCCESSFULLY
ADVOCATED FOR SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. TWO MILLION DOLLARS
EACH FOR YOU SEE.
CSU AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
SUPPORT EQUAL EMPLOYMENT BEST
PRACTICES.
AND TO REPORT ON THE RACIAL
ETHNIC AND GENDER COMPOSITION OF
ITS FACULTY.
THIS HEARING TODAY WILL REVIEW
THE CURRENT STATUS OF FACULTY
DIVERSIFICATION EFFORTS AT UC.
AND PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
MY COLLEAGUES AND MYSELF TO
LEARN HOW UC HAS USE IT'S FUN.
TO ADDRESS FACULTY DIVERSITY
SYSTEM WIDE.
AND TO LEARN OF SOME OF THE
CAMPUS SPACE AS WELL.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN THE COMING
LEGISLATIVE SESSION THERE WILL
BE OVERSIGHT HEARINGS.
ON THE SAME TOPIC COVERING
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
I I WOULD JUST ADD THAT I WAS
RECENTLY AT THE REGENTS MEETING
AT UCLA WHERE I HEARD THE
REGION'S DISCUSSING THE SAME
TOPIC THAT WE ARE HERE
DISCUSSING TODAY.
SO WE WILL BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST
SPEAKERS TODAY WHO WILL PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
FACULTY DIVERSITY.
AND THE CURRENT LEGAL LANDSCAPE
BUT BEFORE I BRING UP.
THE THE FIRST PANEL --
THANKFUL TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM WHO JUST JOINED IS AND IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO GIVE ANY
OPENING REMARKS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM.
I'M GLAD TO BE HERE AND I'M NOT
CONTAGIOUS.
WE'RE GLAD YOU'RE HERE BUT I CAN
BARELY TALK SO.
MY WIFE THINKS THAT'S A GOOD
THING.
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
SO WITH THAT LET ME INTRODUCE.
OF PRESIDENT OF FOOTHILL COLLEGE
TUY T. NEWMAN [inaudible]
EN.
THE ADVOCACY DIRECTOR OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
SERRA RC.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBER.
A MY NAME IS TWEETY WHEN I'M
PRESIDENT OF FOOTHILL COLLEGE --
GOOD AFTERNOON ALSO TO ADD THE
UC COLLEAGUES AND I SEE ALSO OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COLLEAGUES AND
IN THE FOR MICHAEL HERE TODAY IS
TWO FOLD.
ONE IS TO TALK ABOUT THE WHY AND
ALSO TO TALK ABOUT THE HOUSE.
WHY IS FACULTY DIVERSITY
IMPORTANT AND HOW IS THAT
POSSIBLE IN LIGHT OF PROP TWO
ALL NIGHT?
BUT BEFORE I DO SO I FIRST OF
ALL WANT TO THANK YOU ARE NOT
ONLY FOR THE INVITATION TO BE
HERE AND TO TRUST YOU.
ABOUT ALSO TO KEEP THIS ISSUE IT
MATTERS FOR OUR STUDENTS --
MIGHT I WILL TALK ABOUT.
THE CONVERSATION OF FACULTY
DIVERSITY AND IN YOUR PACKET YOU
HAVE OF MY FLIGHTS BUT I WILL
NOT GO THROUGH EACH SIDE INSTEAD.
SPEAK LARGELY AND THEN ADDRESS
OF CERTAIN ASPECTS OF THE FLIGHT.
WHY IS IT IMPORTANT FACULTY
DIVERSITY IN THIS IS A CRITICAL
QUESTION ACTUALLY IN THE LEGAL
CONTEXT IT IS IMPORTANT TO STATE?
IN OUR EQUAL PROTECTION CLAUSE
ANALYSIS TO STATE WHY WHAT IS
THE COMPELLING REASON FOR
FACULTY DIVERSITY AND THE
COMPELLING REASON.
IS OUR STUDENTS.
WE IN THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ACTUALLY HAVE A SEMINAL
CASE AND IT WAS ACTUALLY
CONDUCTED BY A YOU SEE --
COLLIE A PROFESSOR OF ECONOMICS
OF DOING A RESEARCH HE WAS
ACTUALLY DOING RESEARCH ON OF
POVERTY ISSUES WITH REGARDS TO
WORKFORCE AND HE STUMBLED ON
SOME VERY COMPELLING DATA.
AT OUR SISTER COLLEGE DIEM THE
COLLEGE WHAT HE FOUND WAS THAT
STUDENTS WHO WERE BEING EDUCATED
BY FACULTY OF COLOR PARTICULARLY
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LATINO
FACULTIES.
THAT THE EQUITY GAP ACTUALLY
CLOSES UP 251%.
AND IT WAS NOTHING THAT THE
FACULTY MEMBERS DID BUT INSTEAD
IT WAS HOW THE STUDENTS RECEIVED
THE INFORMATION FROM THE FACULTY
MEMBER.
THIS IS REALLY CRITICAL IN THE
CONVERSATION OF THE WHY AND
OFTENTIMES WE SPEED THROUGH IT
VERY QUICKLY BUT IT'S CRITICAL
IN TERMS OF HAVING HARD DATA.
HARD SCIENCE RESEARCH THE
EDUCATIONAL BENEFIT FOR STUDENTS
OF COLOR WITH REGARDS TO FACULTY
DIVERSITY AND REALLY ACTUALLY
RESEARCH IN THE K. TWELVE HAS
SHOWN THE FACULTY OF COLOR
ACTUALLY BENEFIT ALL STUDENTS
NOT JUST STUDENTS OF COLOR.
I'M LET ME DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION
TO PAGE FIVE THIS FIFTH SLIDE.
AND THE CONCLUSION.
OF OF THE THAT YOU SEE PROFESSOR
UC SANTA CRUZ PROFESSOR OF
ROBERT FARLEY HE FOUND STRONG
POSITIVE IN ROOM BUS MINORITY
INTERACTION EFFECTS FOR ALL
OUTCOMES EXAMINED.
THAT INCLUDES GRADES WHETHER
THIS STUDENT STAYS IN THE CLASS
WHETHER THEY PASSED ETCETERA.
HE ALSO SQNG VERY SMALL VERY
STRONG POSITIVE --
OWN RACE INTERACTION WITH FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND AFRICAN
AMERICANS LATINOS ALSO HAD
STRONG STUDENT SUCCESS FOR LET
DENOTE STUDENTS.
OF BUT FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS THE THE EFFECT WAS EVEN
STRONGER FROM A STUDENT SUCCESS
STANDPOINT.
AND WHAT HE FOUND WAS WHAT
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN IS THAT ROLE
MODELING THE FACT SO FEEL FREE.
TO PULL DOWN HIS RESEARCH HE HAS
DONE AND THIS IS THE RESEARCH
THAT WE'VE BEEN USING IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT FACULTY DIVERSITY.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO HAVE
RESEARCH THAT LOCAL THAT'S REAL
THAT'S LIVE AND ALL THAT WOULD
BE ALSO A SUGGESTION FOR ALL
COLLEAGUES DOING THE WORK IS TO
REALLY HAVE RESEARCH THAT'S
GROUNDED.
AND REAL OF FOR OUR COLLEAGUES.
HOW?
NOW IN LIGHT OF OUR KNOWING THAT
THIS IS COMPELLING THE QUESTION
IS HOW IS IT POSSIBLE FOR US TO
DO THIS IN LIGHT OF PROP.
TWO OH NINE AS YOU SEE AND SLIDE --
SET AT SIX OUTSIDE SEVEN YEARS
PROP TWO ALL NINE OF AS YOU WE
KNOW WAS A STUDENT INITIATIVE
THAT BASICALLY SAID WE SHALL NOT
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST OR GRANT
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT BASED ON
RACE AND IN THE CONVERSATION WE
HAVE TODAY.
IN THE CONTEXT OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION A BILL TO TALK ABOUT
FACULTY DIVERSITY WITHIN THE
CONCEPT OF PROP.
TWO OH NINE AND WHAT'S CRITICAL
IS THE NEXT SLIDE AND IT'S
SOMETHING WHEN I WAS IN TRUMP
GENERAL COUNSEL FOR THE STATE
SYSTEM COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
OFFICE CANCERS OFFICE.
IT WAS THE FRAMEWORK AND
COMMUNICATION THAT I DID IN --
TRAINING OUR COLLEAGUES UP AND
DOWN THE STATE AND THAT IS IT'S
TWO SIDES OF THE SAME COIN.
SO ONE SIDE OF THE COIN IS
DEFINITELY ANTI DISCRIMINATION
LAWS AND POP TOOL NINE THAT'S
VERY CLEAR.
BUT THE OTHER SIDE OF THE COIN
IS EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND THE NEED TO
PROMOTE INCLUSION.
IT'S THE SAME SIDE OF THE SAME
IT'S THE TWO SIDES OF THE SAME
COIN.
KNOW WHY IS THIS CRITICAL.
AS UC BERKELEY'S DEAN IRWIN
SHIMMERING SKIER PREMIER
CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLAR HAS SAID
WHAT HAS HAPPENED WITH PROP TWO
OH NINE IS WE HAVE.
BEEN PARALYZED IT MANY TIMES
EVEN AT THE VERY BEGINNING WHEN
PROP TWO ONE NINE WAS PUT IN
PLACE AND QUITE FRANKLY EVEN AS
OF THREE YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS AT
THE STATE'S SYSTEM OFFICE IN
DOING THE TRAINING.
AND GETTING LOCAL --
COLLEGE DISTRICT TRUSTEES TO
VOTE ONFACULTY DIVERSITY AS A
CRITICAL.
ELEMENT THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO
ARE AFRAID OF EVEN USING THE
WORD DIVERSITY.
AND AFRAID THAT THAT CONCEPT
ITSELF IS A VIOLATION OF PROP
TWO OH NINE AND THAT IS NOT TRUE --
AND SO WHAT IS HAPPENING IN OF
THE SAME COIN AND CONSIDERING
THE PARALYSIS OF ANALYSIS OF
PROP TWO OH NINE OUT QUITE
FRANKLY I THINK WE NEED TO SHOW
ONE SIDE EVEN MORE SO BECAUSE OF
THE LANGUAGE HAS BEEN MORE SO ON
ONE SIDE.
THAT SAID HOW IS IT POSSIBLE FOR
THE STATE LEGISLATURE FOR SYSTEM
LEADERS TO BE ABLE TO INFUSE
THAT SECOND SIDE OF THE COIN.
WHAT WHAT YOU WOULD SEE IN THE
PACKET IS IN EDUCATION CODE IN
TITLE FIVE THERE IS A VERY
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE AROUND
DIVERSITY THERE'S VERY SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE AROUND PROMOTION OF
INCLUSION?
THIS TYPE OF LANGUAGE IN LAW
ACTUALLY ALLOWS US TO SHOW THAT
OTHER SIDE OF THE SAME COIN AND
SO I ENCOURAGE YOU AS YOU LOOK.
INTO HOW WE CAN HELP OUR ALL OUR
SYSTEMS AT IN THIS ARENA THAT IS
ONE THING YOU CAN DO IS
EMPHASIZE THAT OTHER SIDE THAT
EQUAL EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY.
WHEN I WAS AT THE STATE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE I ALSO PUT
FORTH A LEGAL MEMO OF SPELLING
OUT THE LEGAL PARAMETERS POP
TOOL NINE AND OTHER THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE SAME COIN?
AND I ALSO TALKED ABOUT FREE
HIRING PROCESS SEES DURING
HIRING PROCESS HE'S AND PULLS
HIRING PROCESS THESE THOSE THREE
HAVE TO BE THOUGHT OF VERY
CLEARLY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
FACULTY DIVERSE STATE. ONE OF
THE THINGS I ALSO TALKED ABOUT
IN THE LEGAL OPINION IS AROUND
HOW TO ANALYZE DATA.
HOW DO YOU ANALYZE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
DESPERATE IMPACT ETCETERA?
AND SO AS YOU WILL SEE IN --
SLIDE.
FIFTEEN I LAID OUT A CHART.
OF AND I TALKED ABOUT THE 80%
RULE IN ANALYZING --
AND THE FOUR FIFTHS RULE IN
ANALYZING DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT I ALSO TALK ABOUT
EXCLUSIONARY AFFECT EXCLUSIONARY
AFFECT IS ESSENTIALLY THE
CONCEPT.
OF SOMETHING THAT IS PUT FORTH
AS A PROCESS A PRACTICE A RULE
THAT ON ITS FACE IS NOT RACIALLY
DISCRIMINATORY BUT HAS AN
EXCLUSIONARY.
OF RACE DISCRIMINATION A ONE
EXAM.
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE WORLD
IS THE MINIMUM QUALIFICATION TO
BE A FACULTY IS A MASTERS DEGREE
YET MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE
A PEACH DE L. REQUIREMENT
INSTEAD.
AND CONSIDERING THE CHALLENGES
ARE YOU SEE COLLEAGUES ARE
HAVING AROUND.
PHD CANDIDATES OF COLOR WHAT IS
THE LIKELIHOOD THEN OF HAVING
CANDIDATES OF COLOR.
APPLYING TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SO WHAT LOOKED LIKE AN
EFFORT TO INCREASE THE RIGOR AND
YOU KNOW OF OF OF GRAVITAS OF
OUR FACULTY MEMBERS WITH THE PHD.
IT ACTUALLY HAS AN EXCLUSIONARY
AFFECT FOR FOLKS OF COLOR
MISSILE THINGS LIKE THAT ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN ONE
ANALYZES THE DATA AND I'M VERY
GLAD ARE YOU SEE SYSTEM --
I SAW ALL THE INFORMATION FROM
THE UCLA FOR INSTANCE WERE VERY
MUCH MAKING THE CASE THE
COMPELLING CASE FOR THE
EDUCATIONAL BENEFIT OF FACULTY
DIVERSITY.
AND ALL OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE VERY
RICH DATA IT'S TIME FOR US TO
NOW GIVE SOME NUMERICAL
UNDERSTANDING OF THOSE STATUS
AND DO SOME REGULAR ANALYSIS
WHICH I'M SURE THEY'RE DOING BUT
I THINK IT'S MORE IMPORTANT THAT
WE KEEP IT IN THE FOREFRONT.
ARE IN CLOSING I JUST WANT TO
SAY IN MY LAST SLIDE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE REALLY
BENEFITS GREATLY FROM THE UC
SYSTEM AND ITS DIVERSIFICATION
WE HAVE A LAW PATHWAY PROGRAM
TWO PLUS TWO PLUS.
THREE IS A STATE WIDE PATHWAY
PROGRAM FOR OF LAW SCHOOLS FOR
THE UC ARE HAVE SIGNED AN AMMO
YOU WITH TWENTY SIX COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND TWENTY TWO HIGH
SCHOOLS. TO REALLY CREATE THAT
PIPELINE SO IT'S NOT JUST
DIVERSIFICATION OF FACULTY BUT
ALSO DIVERSIFICATION OF THE
LEGAL PROFESSION WERE BY THE UC
SYSTEM BECOMES A CRITICAL
PARTNER FOR US.
SO WITH THAT SAID I'D BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN DO NOT --
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON SUCH A CRITICAL
TOPIC.
MY NAME IS THERE ARE SEEING ON
THE SENIOR POLICY DIRECTOR OF
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY WE ARE NONPROFIT
COALITION OF EDUCATION CIVIL
RIGHTS AND BUSINESS LEADERS
SEEKING TO EXPAND COLLEGE ACCESS.
AND STUDENT SUCCESS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR RESEARCH
COALITION BUILDING AND POLICY
ADVOCACY.
EARLIER THIS YEAR RE RELEASED A
GROUNDBREAKING GROUNDBREAKING
REPORT ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
RACIAL AND GENDER INCLUSION IN
HIGHER EDUCATION LEADERSHIP.
IN SUPPORTING STUDENT SUCCESS
THE REPORT ANALYZES STUDENT
FACULTY AND SENIOR LEADERSHIP
ACROSS OUR PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS.
IT FINDS THAT ARE COLLEGE
LEADERS AND FACULTY ARE NOT
REFLECTIVE OF THE DIVERSITY OF
OUR STUDENTS EVEN WHILE WE KNOW
THAT THESE LEADERS ARE KEY TO
PRODUCING MORE COLLEGE GRADUATES
IN CLOSING RACIAL EQUITY GAPS.
ONE ONLY NEEDS TO SET FOOT ON
ONE OF OUR PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES TO SEE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE TAPESTRY OF
STUDENTS ARE REFLECTED IN THE
CLASSROOM.
AS A YOUNG WITH THE NOT UC SANTA
BARBARA I REALLY SAW MYSELF AND
MY PROFESSORS OUR CAMPUS
LEADERSHIP.
LIKE MANY WE INTERVIEWED IT HAD
AN IMPACT IN MY INITIAL COLLEGE
EXPERIENCE AND CONFIDENCE OF
BEING ON CAMPUS.
TODAY I WILL SHARE A MAJOR
FINDINGS FROM THE LEFT OUT
REPORT AS IT RELATES TO THE
LEADERSHIP AND FIGHT FACULTY
DIVERSITY ANALYSIS WE DID FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA --
I WANT TO NOTE THAT THOSE
STATISTICS I WILL BE --
MENTIONING ARE IN PAGES SIX AND
NINE OF THE EXECUTIVE SUMMARY
YOU WERE PROVIDED. TO HELP
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE LANDSCAPE --
WE KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION TO BE THE MOST
DIVERSE IN THE WORLD A TREND
THAT WILL ONLY INCREASE AS 76%
OF K. THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS
TODAY OUR STUDENTS OF COLOR.
A WIDE MAJORITY OF STUDENTS AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
REFLECT THE CHANGING
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE STATE.
NEARLY THREE A FOR YOU SEE
STUDENTS OR 74% IDENTIFIED AS
NON WHITE.
STUDENTS AT THE UC ARE 39% ASIAN
AMERICANS HAWAIIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER WHICH I WILL BE
REFERRING TO AS ON P. FOR THE
REST OF MY PRESENTATION. 26% LET
NEXT 26% WHITE AND 4% AFRICAN
AMERICAN.
YET DESPITE THE RICH DIVERSITY
OF OUR STUDENT BODY WITH A TRUE
LACK OF DIVERSITY IN BOTH
TENURED AND NON TENURED FACULTY
POSITIONS AT THE UC.
TENURED FACULTY AT THE UC ARE
70% WHITE 16% ON P. 7% LOT NECKS
AND 3% AFRICAN AMERICAN.
NON TENURED FACULTY AT THE UC OR
62% WHITE 26% ON P. 5% LOT NEXT
AND 2% AFRICAN AMERICAN.
RECOGNIZING IT THIS MISMATCHING
REPRESENTATION WE KNOW THAT
UNLESS INSTITUTIONS ARE
INTENTIONAL ABOUT WHO THEY HIRE
SIMPLY HIRING MORE FACULTY IN
FULL TIME POSITIONS DOES NOT
NECESSARILY MAKE THEM MORE
DIVERSE.
BECAUSE HIRING OFTEN OCCURS
THROUGH EXISTING NETWORKS IT OFF
IT TENDS TO REPLICATE RATHER
THAN DISRUPT DEMOGRAPHIC
PATTERNS. TO BE CLEAR IF
PROFESSORS ARE ONLY REACHING OUT
TO OTHER ACADEMICS THROUGH
TRADITIONAL RECRUITMENT ROUTES
AND NOT FOCUSED ON OTHER
INTENTIONAL INCLUSIVE MEANS OF
IDENTIFYING AND RECRUITING
TALENTS.
WE WILL NOT DIVERSIFY OUR
FACULTY APPLICANT POOL WE WILL
NOT HIRE MORE DIVERSE FACULTY
AND WE WILL NOT DISTRACT
INEQUITIES.
AS CONCERNING AS THE STATISTICS
MAYBE THAT DIVERSITY CHALLENGE
AT THE YOU SEE IS ALSO ONE OF
GENDER.
FOLLOW MAJORITY OF UNIVERSITY
STUDENTS ARE FEMALE FACULTY IN
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS FOR MAIN
HEAVILY MALE.
FACULTY POSITIONS THAT YOU SEE
ARE HEAVILY SKEWED TOWARDS MEN
WOMEN ONLY HOLD 33% OF TENURED
POSITIONS ACROSS THE SYSTEM.
THERE IS SOMEWHAT BETTER GENDER
REPRESENTATION AND NON TENURED
POSITIONS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
WHICH 44% ARE OCCUPIED BY WOMEN.
RACIAL INEQUITIES IN FACULTY
REPRESENTATION ARE FURTHER
COMPOUNDED IN REPRESENTATION AT
THE ACADEMIC SENATE'S FOR THE
CAMPUSES AND THE UNIVERSITY
ITSELF.
THIS IS CONCERNING GIVEN THE
ROLE ACADEMIC SENATE'S PLAN
ESTABLISHING POLICIES WHICH CAN
DRAMATICALLY IMPACT THE ABILITY
FOR STUDENTS OF COLOR TO ACCESS
AND PRIVATE THE UNIVERSITY. ONE
EXAMPLE OF ACADEMIC DECISION
MAKING IS IN ANY CURRICULAR OR
DEGREE CHANGES FOR INSTANCE ANY
CHANGES TO COURSE REQUIREMENTS
FOR MAJOR MUST BE APPROVED BY
THE ACADEMIC SENATE.
ANY PROPOSAL TO ESTABLISH A NEW
MAY CAN YOU MAJOR MUST BE
APPROVED BY THE ACADEMIC SENATE.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THOSE IN
POSITIONS TO INFLUENCE ECONOMIC
POLICY SO SIGNIFICANTLY CAN
UNDERSTAND THE EXPERIENCES OF
THE STUDENTS IMPACTED YET WE
FIND THAT BOTH THE CAMPUS AND
SYSTEM LEVELS OF ACADEMICS
SENATE'S. EIGHT OUT OF TEN
MEMBERS ARE WHITE WEALTHIER THAN
THREE OF TODAY'S YOU SEE
STUDENTS ARE WHITE.
ACADEMIC SENATE'S FOR UC
CAMPUSES ARE 80% BY 11% ON P. 5%
LATIN ACTS 3% AFRICAN AMERICAN.
AND THE ACADEMIC CENTER FOR THE
UNIVERSITY A LARGE THE MIRRORS
THE SAME DATA.
AS YOU NOTED IN THE MAY HEARING
OF THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE
ON THE MASTER PLAN SHERMAN T.
NOW WE HAVE LONG LAMENTED THESE
CHALLENGES AT THE UNIVERSITY.
WE HOPE THAT TODAY PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO NOT ONLY BRING
FURTHER ATTENTION ON THE NEED TO
MAKE FACULTY AN ACADEMIC SENATE
POSITIONS MORE INCLUSIVE BUT
ALSO IDENTIFY PRACTICAL NEXT
STEPS TOWARDS THAT END.
IN THAT LIGHT WE'D LIKE TO OFFER
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS.
FIRST WE MUST ADDRESS THE FRONT
END OF THE ISSUE BY
UNDERSTANDING THE DEMOGRAPHICS
OF APPLICANT POOLS FOR FACULTY
POSITIONS.
WE OFTEN HEAR THAT A BARRIER TO
INCREASING FACULTY DIVERSITY IS
AT THE APPLICANT POOL IS NOT
DIVERSE.
HOWEVER REPORT POINTS OUT THAT
OVER THREE THOUSAND DIVERSE
STUDENTS EARNED DOCTORATE
DEGREES FROM THE CSU AND YOU SEE
COMBINED MEETING THE MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS FOR FACULTY
POSITIONS AT UC CAMPUSES.
GIVEN THAT WE KNOW THE DIVERSE
STUDENT POPULATIONS ARE
RECEIVING ADVANCED DEGREES MORE
MUST BE DONE TO ENSURE THAT THE
STUDENTS UNDERSTAND THEIR
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN
THE UC.
ADDITIONALLY RECOGNIZING THE
IMMENSE POWER THAT ACADEMIC
SENATES HAVE MEMBERSHIP ROSTER
SHOULD BE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE AND
UPDATED WITH DEMOGRAPHIC DATA.
FINALLY WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S EFFORT AND TO
INVEST IN FACULTY DIVERSITY AND
THOSE INVESTMENT SHOULD COME
WITH CLEAR ACCOUNTABILITY GOALS
AND METRICS AND EVALUATING
EFFICACY.
RESOURCES ALONE ARE UNLIKELY TO
YIELD THE DESIRED OUTCOMES AND
WE MUST SCALE WHAT WE KNOW WORKS.
WITHOUT QUESTION CALIFORNIA'S
PRESENT AND FUTURE WELL BEING
DEPEND ON THE SUCCESS OF OUR
DIVERSE STUDENT BODY.
CHEATS IMPROVING STUDENT SUCCESS
IS ENSURING CENTERS OF POWER AND
LEADERSHIP I CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
REFLECT THE NEEDS EXPERIENCES
AND STRENGTH OF THE CURRENT AND
FUTURE STUDENT BODY.
SO THAT THEY CHAMPION POLICIES
AND PRACTICES THAT STUDENTS.
THAT WORK STARTS A THRACIAN
ENGENDER DIVERSE LEADERS AND
FACULTY AND THAT WORK IS --
CHEN AN OVERDUE.
THANK YOU AND I ALSO HAVE WITH
ME TODAY OUR SENIOR RESEARCH
ANALYST WHO CAN HELP ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
REPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE --
I I HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS.
SO I I HEARD AND YOU SHARE THE
DATA.
AND RESEARCH SUPPORTS THE IDEA
THAT A DIVERSE FACULTY --
IS -- GOOD.
AND POSITIVE FOR AT ACHIEVEMENT
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT AND ALSO
FOR CAMPUS CLIMATE.
IN IN YOUR OPINION.
UP DO YOU WOULD YOU SAY THAT THE
UC SYSTEM SHARES.
IN THOSE BELIEFS TODAY.
IN YOUR OPINION DO YOU DO YOU
FEEL OR THINK THAT YOU SEE
SHARES THAT [inaudible]
IDEA CONCEPT.
WOULD YOU LIKE.
I THINK.
I THINK THE LEADERSHIP
AND THE REGION'S --
AND MANY OF OTHERS INCLUDING FOR
INSTANCE --
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE GENERAL
COUNSEL'S OFFICE FOR THE UC
SYSTEM PRESIDENT APOLLO TANO.
AND SOMEBODY OTHER HAVE PROBABLY
HAVE BEEN THE MOST SUDDENLY
AROUND THE ISSUE OF FACULTY
DIVERSITY --
I DO BELIEVE THAT THEY BELIEVE
ARM AND IN FACT --
IT CUTTING EDGE AROUND SOME
MEASURES LIKE MICHAEL A QUESTION
OF RACIAL CONSCIOUSNESS IMPLICIT
BIAS SIX CETERA.
AND SO I ACTUALLY WHEN I DID MY
LEGAL OPINION I LOOKED AT THE
UC'S OF LEGAL OPINION.
ON THE MATTER TO SEE WHAT I
COULD WE A DRAW FROM THAT FOR
OUR OLD SYSTEM OF FOR THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
I THINK THE CHALLENGE IS QUITE
FRANKLY IS WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
ISSUES OF RACE THERE'S AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF NEED FOR
RACIAL CONSCIOUSNESS AND AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF UNDERSTANDING
AROUND IMPLICIT BIAS.
AND BIAS COMES OUT IN WAYS THAT
WE COULD NEVER IMAGINE AND EVEN
THE MOST OF PROGRESSIVE MINDED
PEOPLE HAVE ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
BIAS AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S REALLY CRITICAL IS TO
TRAINING AROUND IMPLICIT BIAS
WHICH THE USE OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DOING.
I UNDERSTAND THE UC SYSTEM IS
ALSO IN THAT ARENA TO ALL BUT
FOR ALL THOSE REASONS THOSE BIAS
COMES OUT IN MAY BE GUYS WITHIN
THE CONCEPT OF WEIGHT PROP TWO
OH NINE DOESN'T ALLOW US TO DO
THAT OR WAIT DIVERSITY HOW DOES
RACIAL DIVERSITY COME INTO PLAY
IN.
THAT COULD BE SEEN AS
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT EXCITER.
SO HOW THAT COMES OUT IN THIS IS
EXPRESSLY THE CASE OUT OF
COMMITTEE LEVEL WHEN PEOPLE ARE
SELECTING AT EIGHT MORE
LOCALIZED LEVEL THE JUST THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE CAMPUS OR THE
SYSTEM.
SO IT'S REALLY CRITICAL FOR ALL
THIS MESSAGING TO REALLY COME
DOWN AND BE A COMPLETELY
CHAMPION BY PEOPLE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
YEAH I MEAN I I THINK I WOULD
JUST ADD THAT WE APPRECIATE AND
ARM.
THE INCREASED ATTENTION AND
FOCUS ON THE BENEFITS OF TO
STUDENT LEARNING RETENTION AND
SUCCESS OF OF FACULTY DIVERSITY
AND WE HOPE THAT OUR SYSTEM
LEVEL PARTNERS IN THE ACADEMIC
COMMUNITY UNDERSTAND THE
BENEFITS --
BUT UNTIL WE SEE INVESTMENTS AND
DIVERSIFICATION THE VARYING
BODIES --
THAT NEED TO MEET OF THE
STUDENTS WE SPOTLIGHTING THE
ISSUE ALONE AND WE ALSO WE NEED --
TO TEXT REMAIN COMMITTED.
IT YEAH MISTER CHAIR.
IF I MAY ADD THE EFFORT THAT
YOU'RE DOING IN ENSURING THE
LEVEL OF ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
E. L. FUNDING AND JUST LARGELY
THE ISSUE IS REALLY CRITICAL ONE
OF THE TWELVE STUDIES THAT SHOWN
TO HOW IT LIMITED IMPLICIT BIAS.
IS WHEN YOU ACTUALLY AND IT'S A
CHICAGO STUDY OF POLICE OFFICERS
WHEN YOU TELL THEM THAT YOU ARE
LOOKING FOR RACIAL BIAS THE BIAS
GOES AWAY.
AND WHAT WAS CRITICAL IS FOR THE
STATE LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE TO
KEEP THIS TOPIC.
OF VERY FRONT AND CENTER BECAUSE
BY DOING THAT AND MONITORING AT
THE SYSTEM WILL RESPOND.
AND SO I I HIGHLY ENCOURAGE YOU
TO COMMUTING YOU THAT MONITORING
LEVEL [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
SRC WHEN YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
MAKE UP OF THE IS --
THE FACULTY SENATE.
COULD YOU EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT
MORE BECAUSE I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY IF IF THE FACULTY IS --
THIS COMPOSITION.
YOU YOU YOU MAKE REFERENCE TO
THE FACT THAT THE FACULTY SENATE
IS EVEN LESS DIVERSE.
THAN THE FACULTY AND GENERAL
WHITE WHY IS THAT THE CASE.
WELL I THINK YOU KNOW THE
ACADEMIC SENATE IS A VOLUNTARY
FOR AT THAT TIME FACULTY NITA
ELECTED TO SERVE ON AND I THINK
A LOT OF TIMES IN THE IN THE
RESEARCH WE'VE DONE IN
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH
ACADEMIC SAID A LOT OF TIMES.
THEY'RE NOT BEING OUT REACHED
TWO ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
SERVING ON THE ACADEMIC SENATE
NECESSARILY OR THEY DON'T I'M.
THERE OFTEN TIED UP KIND OF
DOING A LOT EFFORTS SO OR TRYING
TO HELP OUR STUDENTS OF COLOR IN
OTHER OF VARIOUS WAYS AND FEEL
LIKE THEY DON'T HAVE THE THE
TIME COMMITMENT TO SERVE ON THE
ACADEMIC SENATE AND SO I THINK
MORE RESEARCH ARE MARKED.
OUT REACHES NEEDED --
TO OUR FACULTY TO ENSURE THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND --
THESE POSITIONS ARE OPEN TO THEM
AND THAT THEY SHOULD THAT THEIR
COURAGE.
TO SERVE ON THOSE BODIES SO FOR
EXAMPLE.
IN YOU SEE NOT ALL TENURED
FACULTY BELONG TO THE ACADEMICS
AND I'M A YOU KNOW IT VARIES
ACROSS --
THE SYSTEM CAMPUS IN TERM OF
WHAT THE REQUIREMENTS ARE FOR
I'M SERVING ON ACADEMICS AND
IT'S BUT WHAT WE CAN HEAR MORE
YEAH WE CAN HEAR MORE FROM THE
ACADEMIC SAID IT BUT IT DID.
I'M WE ACTUALLY HAVE A WHOLE --
ANALYSIS IN OUR REPORT THAT KIND
OF OUTLINES THE DIFFERENT --
RULES AND REGULATIONS OF THE
ACADEMIC SENATE'S BY SYSTEM IN
CAMPUS BECAUSE IT DOES.
VERY FOR N. --
IF YOU WOULD LITERACY CAN YOU
SAY MORE ABOUT THE MANAGEMENT.
THE DIVERSITY OF MANAGEMENT --
THAT THIS STUDY YOUR STUDY I
SURE DID BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT FACULTY BUT WE'RE
ALSO INTERESTED.
IN --
ADMINISTRATORS AS WELL AS I
MENTIONED IN MY REMARKS ARE
REPORT WAS UNIQUE IN THAT IT
ANALYZE CAMPUS DIVERSITY BEYOND
JUST FACULTY IT LOOKED AT SENIOR
LEADERSHIP ON CAMPUS AS WELL AS
SYSTEM LEADERSHIP AND GOVERNING
BOARD DIVERSITY --
SO THE REPORT FINDS THAT THERE
DIVERSITY CHALLENGES AT THOSE
LEVELS FOR THE UC --
TO FOR SENIOR LEADERSHIP AT UC
CAMPUSES WHICH IS --
FOR INSTANCE CHANCELLOR'S VICE
CHANCELLORS AND MEMBERS OF THE
CHANCELLOR'S CABINET I'M 70% ARE
WHITE AND NEARLY TWO OUT OF FIVE
YOU SEE STUDENTS ARE ON P. YET
FEWER THAN.
ONE IN TEN CAMPUS LEADERS ARE ON
WE ALSO LOOKED AT THE UC BOARD
OF REGENTS THE APPOINTMENT SO
I'M AT THE APPOINTED MEMBERS OF
THE UC BOARD OF REGENTS.
AND WE FIND THAT THERE SIXTY
PURCHASE 62% ARE WHITE 23% LOT
NEXT 8% AFRICAN AMERICAN AND 8%
ON P..
A AND WE'RE GONNA ADD SOMETHING
I THINK.
WE WANTED --
YES -- I
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP IN OUT ON
THE QUESTION OF WHY OF FACULTY
OF COLOR NOT PARTICIPATING IN
ACADEMIC SENATE LEASE FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THERE'S A STUDY THAT ONE
DISSERTATION OF THE YEAR
NATIONALLY THAT LOOKED AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN ORANGE
COUNTY IN LA.
AND THE RESEARCH FOUND THAT
FACULTY OF COLOR EVEN AFTER
BEING HIRED OFTEN FEEL ISOLATED
ON CAMPUS.
AND AS A RESULT --
SIMPLY DO A GREAT JOB TEACHING
BUT DO NOT ENGAGE IN THE COLLEGE
GOVERNANCE ARE INCLUDING
ACADEMIC SENATE.
AND SO IT'S REALLY CRITICAL AS
WE LOOK ABOUT OUTREACH IN
RECRUITING DIVERSE FACULTY
APPLICANTS OF AND AND THEN
SELECTING THEM BUT ALSO EVEN
POST HIRING.
ENSURING THE RIGHT ONBOARDING
AND CONTINUAL SUPPORT A FACULTY
OF COLOR SO THAT THEY CAN FEEL
ENGAGE AND NOT BE RACIALLY
ISOLATED ON CAMPUS --
SO IF THEY'RE NOT EVEN
PARTICIPATING AT THE LOCAL
ACADEMICS AND IT BECOMES EVEN
MORE DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
PARTICIPATE AT THE STATEWIDE
ACADEMIC SENATE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SURE BLOOM [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WILL GO AHEAD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION AND
WE'LL GO AHEAD GO TO OUR SECOND
PANEL.
SO -- THEIR
SECOND PANEL WILL FOCUS ON
SYSTEM WIDE EFFORTS. TO
IMPROVING FACULTY DIVERSITY.
I AM PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
HEARING AN UPDATE REGARDING HOW
THE UC HAS USE THE TWO MILLION
DOLLARS PROVIDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
A AN ORDER TO SUPPORT THE MORE
DIVERSITY OF FACULTY.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME.
PROVOST AND EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT.
IN THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
MICHAEL BROWN.
AND VICE PROVOST FOR ACADEMIC
PERSONNEL AND PROGRAMS ALSO FROM
THE UC OFFICES OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT SUSAN CARLSON.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU JAY AND IS THE MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND I DO WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE PRESIDENT OF FOOT
HILL --
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND THE SENIOR
ADVISER POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CAMPAIGN OF COLLEGE ACT
OPPORTUNITY.
I THANK YOU FOR INVITING US HERE
TO DISCUSS WHAT I THINK IT IS
IT'S TRULY A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND THAT'S FACULTY
DIVERSITY AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I AND I COULDN'T AGREE MORE
WITH THE PRESIDENT THAT I I
WOULD HOPE.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WOULD KEEP
THIS THIS MATTER BEFORE BEFORE.
I DO THINK WE HAVE A A
GENERATIONAL OPPORTUNITY --
TO TO BEND THE CURVE.
HERE AND ACCELERATE --
OF OUR OUR OUR EFFORTS AND OUR
OUTCOMES WITH RESPECT. TO
FACULTY DIVERSITY AND I DO WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE TO ADD THAT AT
THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR OF THE
ACADEMIC SENATE.
OF THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
HERE -- ARE
ROBERT MAY AND CAN COME BACK.
NINETY SINCE AND EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR ACADEMIC AFFAIRS
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SAY.
THAT MY HIGHEST PRIORITIES ARE
THREE ONE IS TO ENHANCE THE
ACADEMIC QUALITY OF THE
UNIVERSITY Y. OUT BECAUSE THAT
QUALITY IS WHAT MAKES ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY TO DO UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA MATTER.
ARE OUT TO TO DIVERSIFY THE
PREVENT SORTED.
OUT WITH RESPECT TO WOMEN AND
RACIAL ETHNIC MINORITIES.
WHY NOT BECAUSE THIS BOTH
ADVANCES ACADEMIC QUALITY AND
INNOVATION AND IT IS KEY TO
MAKING MORRELL?
R. THE UNIVERSITY'S ROLE AS ONE
OF CALIFORNIANS INSTRUMENTS OF
HOPE AND OPPORTUNITY.
NUMBER THREE TO ENHANCE THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MORE UNDER
REPRESENTED OUR STUDENTS TO EARN
A UC QUALITY DEGREE.
WHY BECAUSE THIS IS A MARKHAM OF
MOST OBVIOUS ENEFIT --
TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
WHY IS FACULTY DIVERSITY ONE OF
MY HIGHEST PRIORITIES AS PROVOST
ARE -- ALLAH
AND OUR IT'S BECAUSE IT IS
INEXTRICABLY LINKED IN MY MIND
TO THE FIRST PRIORITY --
BECAUSE ALL STUDENTS ARE BETTER
EDUCATED AND PREPARED TO LEAD
CALIFORNIA OUR NATION AND THE
WORLD --
WHEN THEY THERE ARE DIVERSE
PERSPECTIVES IN THE CLASSROOM?
ODD ARE THESE DIVERSE
PERSPECTIVES COME ARE FROM A
DIVERSE FACULTY WHO BRING A WIDE
RANGE OF INTERESTS ABILITIES
LIFE EXPERIENCES WORLD VIEWS --
ARE THAT ENHANCE UC'S TEACHING
OUR RESEARCH AND PUBLIC SERVICE
MISSIONS.
OUT RESEARCH SHOWS THAT WE WILL
ALSO PRODUCE MORE INNOVATIVE AND
SIGNIFICANT RESEARCH WHEN WE
HAVE DIVERSE TEAMS COLLABORATING
ON THE WORK THAT I DO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA'S THE RESEARCH
INVERSE.
AND SO IT AT ARCTIC HERE ARE ARE
OUT CITY IS PART OF THE RICHNESS
OF THE ROYAL JELLY.
ARE OF HIGHER EDUCATION THAT WE
SEEK TO PROVIDE OUR ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS THIS ROYAL JELLY WILL
MAKE QUEEN BEES OF ANY STOOD.
ARE AND I AM A AND AND I BELIEVE
THAT.
ARE I STATED.
I I STATED TO THE BOARD OF
REGENTS AT THEIR MEETING IN
SEPTEMBER AND I WILLCLEARLY
STATE TO YOU NOW THREE THINGS --
WE HAVE MADE RECENT PROGRESS IN
FACULTY DIVERSITY AT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA WE ARE NOT
SATISFIED.
WITH THAT PROGRESS A PROGRESS
HAS BEEN SMALL AND SLOW.
ARE AND WE ARE FULLY AWARE THAT
WE NEED TO DO MUCH MORE AND WE
FULLY INTEND AND HAVE COMMITTED
TO DO MUCH MORE.
AND I WANT TO SE NUMBER THREE
YOU HAVE HELPED.
OUR WITH CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP
WE HAVE A ONCE IN A GENERATION
OPPORTUNITY --
TO REALLY MOVE THE NEEDLE.
THIS REQUIRES COLLECTIVE VISION
OF FOR FAIRNESS AND INCLUSION
EXCELLENCE AND BELONGING.
AT THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
IS PLAYING AND CAN CONTINUE TO
PLAY.
ARE AN IMPORTANT LEADERSHIP AND
COORDINATING ROLE WITH RESPECT
TO THIS COLLECTIVE VISION.
I WITH APPRECIATION AND REYES
CONTINUE.
YOUR PARTNERSHIP WITH US TO
FURTHER --
THIS MORE INCLUSIVE VISION I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE STATE
FOR ALLOCATING TWO MILLION IN
WHAT AND ONE TIME FUNNY BUT IT'S
BEEN FOR EACH YEAR.
SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN ARE TO
SUPPORT EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY PRACTICES THAT YOU
SEE.
AN AD AND AS YOU LISTEN TO OUR
PRESENTATION TODAY.
I HOPE THAT YOU WILL SEE OUR OUR
WORK TO DIVERSIFY TO
PROFESSORIAL.
OUT LEVERAGES AND EXTENDS AT THE
STATE'S DIRECT INVESTMENT IN
THAT EFFORT.
ALTHOUGH OUR VICE PROVOST SUSAN
CARLSON WILL GO INTO SPECIFIC
DETAIL --
LATER ABOUT THE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT OF THE ADDITIONAL STATE
FUNDING I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT --
THAT THE AND THE RESULTS ARE
IMPRESSIVE OUR OB PARTICULARLY
WITH WHAT WE CALL THE ADVANCING
FACULTY DIVERSITY PROGRAM --
IT PROVIDES EVIDENCE AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT'S IMPORTANT.
ARE ODD THAT CONCENTRATED
FUNDING AND PROMISING PRACTICES.
ARE HAS A DIRECT IMPACT ON
IMPROVING DIVERSITY IN HIGH.
ARM OUT SO WHAT HAS YOU SIMPLY
HEARING HELD AT SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY IN OCTOBER.
TWENTY SIXTEEN IN OCTOBER 20157%
OF UC'S ARE LOTTERING FACULTY
WERE UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITIES AND 32% WERE WOMEN.
TODAY ARE 7% OF UC'S LETTERING
FACULTY ARE UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITIES AND NEARLY 34% ARE
WOMEN.
THIS IS FOR ANYBODY WHO WORKS IN
THIS AREA IT LOOKS SMALL --
BUT THIS IS REAL PROGRESS DAHLE
FLOW.
ARE IN PART BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT
BEEN GROWING THE FACULTY UNTIL
LATE UNTIL --
OUT.
MORE AGGRESSIVELY UNTIL RECENTLY
AND NOW WE HAVE LIKE I KEEP
SAYING AND I WILL KEEP SAY WE
HAVE A GENERATIONAL OPPORTUNITY --
TO MAKE STRONG IMPACT ON FACULTY
DIVERSITY GIVE IT.
AT THAT THE UNIVERSITY HAS
INCREASED STUDENT ROMAN WELL
PAST OUR TARGETS AND THE PENDING
RETIREMENT OF OUR AGING FACULTY
MEMBERS.
BOTH OF THOSE CREATE A NEED TO
GROW THE PROFESSORIAL.
AND AND THEREFORE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DIVERSIFY --
AT RECENT HIRES OF LORRAINE
FACULTY ARE MORE DIVERSE --
AD THEN INCUMBENT FACULTY AND
THIS IS --
THAT THAT TO TALK ABOUT IN THE
LAST YEAR 17% OF NEW LADDER RANK
HIGHER AS WELL UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITIES AND 44% MORE WOMEN.
OUT WITH NEW INVESTMENTS BY THE
STATE I COMMIT TO YOU ARE THAT
WE WILL BE IN THE CURVE TOGETHER --
THERE WILL BE MORE RAPID
PROGRESS.
THESE RECENT IMPROVEMENTS IN
HIRING AND RETENTION OF DIVERSE
FACULTY ARE RESULT OF
INTENTIONAL AGGRESSIVE AND MULTI
FACETED EFFORTS.
UNDERTAKEN AT BOTH THE SYSTEM
WIDE IN THE CAMPUS LEVELS.
SO WHAT WORKS AND WHY ARE IN
ADDITION TO THE ADVANCING
FACULTY DIVERSITY PROGRAM THAT
MY COLLEAGUE --
VICE PROVOST CARSON TO DISCUSS
NEXT I'D LIKE TO PROVIDE YOU
WITH BRIEF HIGHLIGHTS OF SOME OF
OUR CURRENT --
A SYSTEM WIDE FACULTY DIVERSITY
EFFORTS THAT HAVE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN INCREASING
FACULTY DIVERSITY WITHOUT THEM
WE BELIEVE ARE YOU SEE WOULD
LOSE GROUND.
SO THEY MUST BE SUSTAINED IF NOT
EXPAND.
OUR FIRST YOU SEE IS COMMITTED
TO HIRING FROM WITHIN AND
GROWING ITS OWN LINE --
TO TO THE FACULTY THROUGH
RESEARCH FELLOWSHIPS
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
FACULTY MENTORING. ONE WAY THAT
WE DO THIS IS THROUGH THE
PRESIDENT'S POST DOCTORAL
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM.
BY THE WAY THE CAMPUS IS LOVE
THAT PROGRAM AND WE HAVE
STRAIGHTENED.
BY OUR OWN REDIRECTION RESOURCES
STRENGTHENED THAT PROGRAM.
ARE OF FOR OVER THREE AND A HALF
DECADES THIS YOUNG FACULTY TO
YOU SEE OUR OUR FACULTY WITH A
CLEAR DEDICATION TO ISSUES OF
EQUITY AND DIVERSITY IN THE
RESEARCH TEACHING.
AND OUTREACH OUR CAMPUSES LOVE
THIS PROGRAM SECONDLY YOU SEE
RECRUIT.
YOU SEE HAVE AN ONLINE ONE STOP.
SHOP FACULTY RECRUITMENT SYSTEM.
WHICH ALLOWS EVERY SINGLE CAMPUS
AT TO LEVERAGE BEST PRACTICES IN
EQUAL EMPLOYMENT STREAMLINED THE
PROCESS.
AND SUPPORT APPLICANTS IN
ACADEMIC DEPARTMENTS
HOLISTICALLY.
ARE CRITICALLY IN IN AND AND
PROVIDE DATA FOR EVALUATING THE
EFFECT OF OUR OF OUR PROGRAM
WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT WE CANNOT
FOOL OURSELVES BY IGNORING THE
ROLE THAT SALARIES PLAY IN
RECRUITING AND RETAINING A
DIVERSE FACULTY IT'S IT'S
IMPORTANT ALL FACULTY BUT IT'S
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO.
THEY'RE SO RARE IN THIS IN THIS
FEAR THEY HAVE OPTIONS IN MANY
OTHER PLACES.
ARE SOLD SO NEXT WEEK ON OCTOBER
THIRTY ONE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE ACADEMIC SENATE --
NO WE JUST DID THIS --
NO NO NO IS COMING NEXT WEEK --
I'M HOLDING A SIMPLE THAT WE WE
HAD ANOTHER SUPPOSE WE HAD
RETREAT --
RECENTLY WITH OUR EBC SEES WITH
THEIR ACADEMIC DEANS WERE THERE
ON ADVANCING FACULTY DIVERSITY
BUT BUTTON BUT NEXT WEEK WE HAVE
A SYMPOSIUM A WITH LEADERS FROM
THE SENATE AND ADMINISTRATION.
TO DISCUSS THE MULTI YEAR
ANALYSIS OF FACULTY SALARIES
CONDUCTED BY THE CAMPUS IS IN
ORDER TO IDENTIFY AND RECTIFY
ANY INEQUITIES THAT ARE BASED ON
GENDER OR RACIAL ETHNICITY.
MY OFFICE HAS BEEN PROVIDING THE
ARE THE PRESIDENT WITH ALL THE
INFORMATION AND DATA --
WE CAN IN ORDER TO MAKE FACULTY
SALARIES COMPETITIVE ANY LIMIT
SITUATIONS OF OF AND A COURT IN
EQUITY.
NECKS LEADERSHIP DOESN'T MATTER --
THE CAMPUS AND SYSTEMWIDE
LEADERSHIP --
DEMONSTRATE OUR AND ARE ARE
CONTINUING TO DEMONSTRATE
COMMITMENT TO DIVERSIFY BY
HAVING POLICIES THAT RECOGNIZE
AND REWARD FACULTY CONTRIBUTIONS.
TO DIVERSITY AND EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY.
BECAUSE LEADERSHIP MATTERS WE
REINFORCE ARE THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF LEADERSHIP WE BELIEVE IN
ACCOUNTABILITY AND BY THE WAY
THAT WAS THAT TOPIC --
AT AT THE RETREAT THAT WE HAD --
OUR LAST WEEK --
JUST LAST WEEK ON RIGHT OCTOBER
SIXTEENTH PROVOST HEX EXPERT
FROM UC DAVIS AND I CONVENE THE
ACADEMIC LEADERSHIP FROM THE
CAMPUS IS THAT I JUST DESCRIBED
TO YOU. TO FOR ADD TO FOCUS ON
BOTH ACCOUNTABILITY I HAVE FOR
ADVANCING OUT OF THE FACULTY
DIVERSITY PROGRAM WE
INTENTIONALLY INVITED THOSE --
THOSE LEADERS THAT I DESCRIBED A
BECAUSE THEY ARE KEY TO THE
EFFORTS TO REACH THE DEPARTMENTS
ON THE GROUND WHERE THE FACULTY
HAVE THEIR HOMES.
ARE I AND AND I THINK WE ALL
FOUND THE VICTORY QUITE
HARDENING OUR PRESIDENT IN THE
PART OF TOWN ARE REPORTED AT THE
SEPTEMBER BOARD.
OF THE REGIONS THAT SHE MEETS
ANNUALLY WITH THE CHANCELLOR'S.
AS PART OF CAMPUS REVIEWS TO
ADDRESS --
STUDENT FACULTY IN DIVERSITY AND
SHE SENT A FOLLOW UP LETTER THAT
INDICATES ARE --
THE DIGEST OF THOSE DISCUSSIONS
AND EXPECTATIONS ARE FOR FOR FOR
OUR FUTURE ACTION SO WHERE DO WE
GO FROM HERE.
OUT WHAT ARE THE NEXT STEPS TO
TAKE US TO THE NEXT LEVEL OF
PROGRESS.
YOU WILL HEAR ARE FROM RIVERSIDE
DAVIS IRVINE CAMPUSES IN THE
NEXT PANEL --
WITH EXAMPLES OF MANY PROGRAMS
AND INITIATIVES ARE AT THE
CAMPUSES THAT ARE TARGETED AT
BUILDING.
A STRONG AND DIVERSE OUR
PROFESSORIAL BUT YOU SEE I WILL
JUST BRIEFLY MENTIONED THAT UC
SAN DIEGO IS HOSTING THE UC
CHECK CONNECTS LATIN MIX --
LEADERSHIP SUMMIT IN LATE
NOVEMBER I'LL BE THERE.
OUR AND LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM MY CHECK CONNECTS AND LET
NEXT COLLEAGUES I AM PLEASED
THAT ARE AMONG THE STATE IS THAT
CHAIR MEDINA YOU'LL BE JOINING
US.
AS WELL.
ARE I AM DEEPLY COMMITTED TO
SCAFFOLDING A MORE. FOR THE
UNIVERSITY.
I THINK THIS IS A NECESSARY PART
OF MAKING THE UNIVERSITY FUTURE
READY AND AND I HAVE WITH THE
DISCUSSIONS I HAD WITH JANET AT
THE TIME OF Y. HIRING.
I WAS VERY CLEAR THAT IF SHE
WASN'T INTERESTED IN THIS BEEN
ADDED NEED DESKTOP AYE AYE TO
ADD IN THE MORNING.
ARE SHE ENDED UP HIRING ME I I
TOOK THAT TO BE SHE WAS
COMMITTED TO THIS AND I HOPE MY
ACTIONS AT THAT TIME HAVE
INDICATED THAT.
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW.
NO SINGLE APPROACH WILL RESULT
IN MORE DIVERSE FACULTY YOU SEE
IS NOW TAKING ACTIVE STEPS TO IS
STRIPPED THEM AND EXPAND OUR
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS.
PRESIDENT APOLLO --
TEN ANNOUNCED ON SEPTEMBER
TWENTY SIX ARE THAT SHE IS
DEDICATING AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN
POINT ONE MILLION ANNUALLY. TO
EXPAND SUCCESSFUL INSTRUCTIONAL
TRAINING.
AND TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT
CREATE PATHWAYS TO THE
PROFESSORIAL FOR DIVERSE
GRADUATE STUDENTS AND
POSTDOCTORAL FELLOWS ARE AND
CREATE NEW PROGRAMS TO ENSURE.
THAT YOU SEE STUDENTS BENEFIT.
FROM A MORE YOU ARE INVESTMENT
THAT HEY HERE TO TO HAVE BEEN
ONE TIME BUT IT'S BEEN IT BUT
IT'S BEEN MADE ONGOING I'M I'M
JUST I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
EXCITED I AM ABOUT THAT.
A DIVERSE AND EXCELLENT FACULTY
IS ESSENTIAL TO THE EDUCATION OF
YOU SEE STUDENTS AND BETTER
EFFECTING THAT DIVERSITY
REQUIRES ROBUST INTERVENTION.
ARE AND PATHWAYS INTO THE
PROFESSOR.
THIS THAT PATHWAYS ORIENTED
APPROACH ARE RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF MULTIPLE IN
INTERVENTION SUSTAINED OVER TIME.
ARE TO IDENTIFY AND CULTIVATE
TALENT.
AND FOR OFFERING INSTRUCTIONAL
PROGRAM SERVICES INCENTIVES THAT
REFLECT THE WAYS THAT SCHOLARS
OF COLOR AND WOMEN EXPERIENCE
THEIR CAREERS WERE ALSO GOING TO
GROW THE VERY SUCCESSFUL
PRESIDENT'S POSTDOCTORAL
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM I SPOKE OF
EARLIER. TO BRING MOST MORE
POSTDOCTORAL FELLOWS TO OUR
CAMPUSES FOR CERTAIN FEELS
PARTICULARLY IN STEM
POSTDOCTORAL FELLOWSHIPS MATTER --
IN TERMS OF GIVING THEM A LEG UP --
ALL ALONG THEIR THEIR ACADEMIC
CAREERS --
IN CLOSING I'D LIKE TO LEAVE A
QUOTE ANY THOUGHT --
BASED UPON IT WITH YOU.
ENCLOSING HIS SPEECHES BOBBY
KENNEDY.
I USED TO SAY.
THAT SOME SEE THINGS AS THEY ARE
DREAMS NEVER WORK.
AND ASK WHY NOT --
WE HAVE NEVER HAD.
THE MOST INCLUSIVE OF FACULTY AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
I AM NOT INTERESTED.
IN THE WHY IS THAT.
AYE AM INTERESTED AND WHY.
WE EN I AND I'M DEDICATED TO
TRYING TO MAKE THAT REALITY
HAPPEN SO ON THE AYE AYE YIELD --
TO SUSAN CARS --
CHAIR MEDINA --
LET ME ADD MY THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
ABOUT OUR HIGH PRIORITY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BUILDING A TALENTED.
INNOVATIVE AND DIVERSE FACULTY.
OUR ADVANCING FACT THE DIVERSITY
PROGRAM --
WHICH YOU'VE SUPPORTED THROUGH
THREE YEARS OF ONE TIME
ALLOCATIONS OF TWO MILLION
DOLLARS HAS LED TO AN
UNPARALLELED FLOURISHING OF
INITIATIVES THAT ARE ALLOWING US
TO EXPERIMENT.
IN NOVEL WAYS.
THE ANNUAL NATURE OF THE FUNDING
HAS MET WE'VE HAD AGGRESSIVE
TIME LINES WE CONTINUED WITH
OTHER EFFORTS IN PROGRAMS
ALREADY UNDER WAY OF COURSE BUT
YOU'VE CREATED AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO TEST AND REPLICATE NEW
INTERVENTIONS THAT MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
THE LEGISLATURE'S CLEAR
ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF THE CHALLENGES
WE FACE HAS BOOSTED MORALE AND
MADE A POWERFUL DIFFERENCE IN
OUR WORK. FOR YOU SEE IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT THAT THE PROGRAM'S
BEEN BASED ON THE VALUES WE HAVE
IS A RESEARCH INSTITUTION AND MY
COLLEAGUE HAS JUST REFERRED TO
THAT AS WELL.
VALUES OF COMPETITION EVALUATION
AND METRICS AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
SO I'D LIKE TO START BY FOCUSING
ON THE RESULTS FROM THE FIRST
TWO YEARS OF THIS FUNDING.
THEN LOOK AT THE CURRENT YEAR IN
CURRENT AT WORK IN YEAR.
THREE IN THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF
THIS PROGRAM WE SAW SOME
EXTRAORDINARY SUCCESSES AFTER
COMPETITIVELY AWARDING FUNDING
FOR SEVEN PILOT PROGRAMS.
IN YOUR TO ALONE FOR OF THESE
PILOTS AVERAGED 31% INCREASE IN
UNDER REPRESENTED MINORITY
FACULTY HIRED.
YOUR ONE INCLUDED PILOTS IN THE
BOARD'S COLLEGE OF ENGINEERING
AT UC RIVERSIDE THE JACOBS
SCHOOL OF ENGINEERING AT UC SAN
DIEGO.
AND THE COLLEGE OF AGRICULTURAL
AND ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCES AT UC
DAVIS.
IN YOUR TO WE HAD PILOTS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF ECONOMICS AT UC
SANTA BARBARA.
THE COLLEGE OF ENGINEERING AT UC
BERKELEY.
BIOMEDICAL SCIENCES IS AT YOU
SEE GO AND SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY
AND ENGINEERING AT UC IRVINE.
BUT ALL TEN CAMPUSES HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED EITHER AS PILOT UNITS
OR COMPARATOR UNITS.
DURING PANEL THREE YOU'LL HEAR
IMPRESSIVE RESULTS FROM
COLLEAGUES AT THREE OF OUR
CAMPUSES WHO HAVE HAD SOME OF
THIS FUNDING.
UC RIVERSIDE IN YEAR ONE TESTED
THE USE THE EARLIEST OF
CONTRIBUTIONS TO DIVERSITY
STATEMENTS.
AND THE AWARD OF A RESEARCH YEAR
TO INCOMING FACULTY.
UC IRVINE FOCUSED ON RECRUITMENT
OF DIVERSE POSTDOCS IN THE
PRESIDENT'S POST DOCTORAL
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM WITH HIGH
SUCCESS.
AND UC DAVIS HAS HAD FUNDING IN
BOTH YOURS ONE AND THREE
EXPERIMENTING WITH A NEW CAMPUS
WIDE INCENTIVE IN THIS CURRENT
YEAR.
AND I HAVE A FEW OTHER DETAILS
OF CAMPUSES WHO ARE NOT HERE TO
SPEAK TO ABOUT THEIR WORK.
IN YOUR ONE FOR EXAMPLE UC SAN
DIEGO IN ENGINEERING THEY HIRED
21% YOU UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITY FACULTY AND 1338% WOMEN
FACULTY BOTH ALL TIME HIGHS.
IN YOUR TO AS I SAID EARLIER
THERE WAS A SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE
IN THE PERCENTAGE OF UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITY AND FEMALE
FACULTY IN ALL FOUR OF THE PILOT
UNITS.
AS I SAID FOR THESE FOUR UNITS
AVERAGE OF 31% INCREASE IN UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITY FACULTY
HIRED.
BUT ALSO A 12% INCREASE IN
FEMALE FACULTY HIRED OVER THE
PREVIOUS TWO YEARS.
THESE RATES WERE NOTABLY HIGHER
THAN THOSE IN THE COMPARED TO
UNITS WHO DID NOT RECEIVE THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
BUT THERE'S ANOTHER CRUCIAL OF
DETAIL TO THIS ESPECIALLY IN
YOUR TO A FOR FUNDING THE STATE
FUNDING HAS TRULY LEVERAGED
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT AT THE
CAMPUS LEVEL IN ALL THREE YEARS
WE'VE SEEN SIGNIFICANT CAMPUS
INVESTMENT IN THESE PROGRAMS.
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS NOT REQUIRED.
THE STRUCTURE OF THIS PROGRAM
HAS CREATED A SENSE OF URGENCY
THROUGH ITS MANDATE THAT EFFORTS
TAKE PLACE IN A SINGLE ACADEMIC
RECRUITMENT CYCLE AND PRESS TO
RECRUITMENT ALMOST ALL START IN
THE FALL AND CONCLUDE BY JULY
WHEN OUR NEW FACULTY.
JOIN US --
SO IT WAS A PUSH TO TO TO TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN HIRING IN
THE COURSE OF THAT SINGLE YEAR
BUT THIS PROGRAM HAS BROUGHT
POWERFUL NEW ACCOUNTABILITY
pADVISORY GROUP THAT TRACKS
PROGRESS OF THE PILOT PROGRAMS
ON A MONTHLY BASIS.
BOTH OF THESE COMPONENTS ARE A
NEW FACTORY IN OUR WORK AT THE
UNIVERSITY.
WE ALSO HAVE SEEN THAT THE
SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM
DEMONSTRATES THE NEED FOR
CERTAIN COMMON PRACTICES STRONG
LEADERSHIP FROM CHAIRS DEANS AND
PROVOSTS.
DELIBERATE EFFORTS TO CHANGE
EVALUATION PRACTICES AND
CAREFULLY PLANNED OUR EACH.
AND THEN JUST A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE CURRENT YEAR HERE THREE OF
THIS FUNDING.
WE'VE CONTINUED THE FOCUS ON
RECRUITMENT AND THIS YEAR HAVE
MADE FOR A NEW PILOT PROGRAM
AWARDS.
ALL DRAW FROM THE SUCCESSFUL
INTERVIEW HERE'S ONE AND TWO
ALSO AT THE REQUEST OF CAMPUS
LEADERSHIP WE'VE CONDUCTED A
SECOND REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS
WITH A FOCUS NOT ON RECRUITMENT.
BUT ON BUILDING AND TESTING
PRACTICES THAT WILL ENSURE WE
RETAIN OUR DIVERSE FACULTY AND
PROVIDE AN INCLUSIVE ACADEMIC
CLIMATE FOR ALL.
BECAUSE OF THE HIGH QUALITY OF
THE PROPOSAL'S PRESIDENT OF
POLITECNICO OF FUNDS SIX OF
THESE RETENTION PROJECTS.
WE WOULD NOT BE AT THIS POINT
WITHOUT THE STATE FUNDING AND
YOUR INSISTENCE ON
ACCOUNTABILITY THROUGH MEANS
SUCH AS THIS.
HERE FEW DETAILS OF WHAT'S NEW
AND EXCITING IN YEAR.
THREE THE LIFE SCIENCES AT UC
BERKELEY ARE REFINING
RECRUITMENT PRACTICES THAT WERE
IMMENSELY SUCCESSFUL IN BERKELEY
ENGINEERING DURING YOUR TO R.
SAID IS FULLY INTEGRATING THE
STUDENTS NEEDS AS THEY PLAN
THEIR PILOT.
AND WHAT'S NEW FACTLY ON OUR ON
CAMPUS NEXT FALL DAY WILL BE
MATCHED WITH EXPERT TEACHING
MENTORS.
THE DISCIPLINE OF MATHEMATICS
HAS SOME OF THE LOWEST
REPRESENTATION OF UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITIES AND
FEMALE FACULTY.
UC RIVERSIDE HAS DESIGNED A BOLD
PILOT TO PIONEER NEW PRACTICES
IN MATH.
AND TO ENSURE WE RETAIN THE
DIVERSE FACULTY OF IT THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE WE'RE FOCUSING ON
PROGRAMS IN THE ARTS HUMANITIES
AND OTHER DISCIPLINES WITH THE
HIGHEST CURRENT REPRESENTATION
OF UNDER REPRESENTED MINORITIES.
WE'RE ALSO TESTING SOME
SUCCESSFUL WAYS TO UNDERSTAND
AND IMPROVE CLIMATE ISSUES AT
THE DEPARTMENT LEVEL.
AND FINALLY SEVERAL THIS YEAR'S
PILOTS ARE ADDRESSING THE ISSUE
OF SERVICE WORK AND IT'S
DISPROPORTIONATELY NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON WOMEN AND
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITIES.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE TIME OR
MONEY TO WASTE E NEED TO MOVE
NOW TO INCREASE OUR CAPACITY TO
TEST MORE INTERVENTIONS AND TO
DEVELOP AND ANALYZE DATA THAT
TELLS US WHERE THE PILOT
INTERVENTIONS ARE WORKING.
AND FRANKLY WHERE THEY'RE NOT.
YOU SEE HAS ABOUT ONE HUNDRED
DEAN LED ACADEMIC UNITS AND WE
HAVE DIRECTLY TOUCHED ONLY A FEW
IT WITH THESE THREE YEARS OF
FUNDING WE WOULD LIKE TO COMMIT.
I WOULD LIKE TO BUILD
COMMITMENTS TO FACULTY DIVERSITY
IN ALL OF OUR UNITS SO THAT WE
CAN TRULY TALK ABOUT
INSTITUTIONAL TRANSFORMATION.
FACULTY INVOLVED TO DATE HAVE
BEEN MOST RESPONSIVE AND THEY
APPRECIATE THE EVIDENCE BASED
TOOLS AND PRACTICES WE'RE
EXPERIMENTING WITH.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO BUILD
THESE PARTNERSHIPS.
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO CONTINUE
MAKING MORE SUSTAIN PROGRESS AND
DISCIPLINES WHERE WOMEN AND
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITIES ARE
STILL IN SMALL NUMBERS.
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING
MATHEMATICS ECONOMICS MANAGEMENT.
AND OTHERS.
BUT WE NEED TO SUPPORT THE WORK
OF THOSE FACULTY IN DISCIPLINES
WHOSE RESEARCH AND TEACHING DEAL
WITH ISSUES OF EQUITY IN ACCESS.
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENTS PEDAGOGY IMMIGRATION
CULTURAL STUDIES ECONOMIC
DISPARITY DISCRIMINATION RACE
ETHNICITY GENDER SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND GENDER
EXPRESSION.
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO EXPAND OUR
COLLECTION.
OF SURVEY INFORMATION AS WELL ON
WHY ARE FACULTY CHOOSE TO LEAVE
YOU SEE.
AN WITH THOSE WHO DECIDE TO STAY
WHITE WHY THEY DO STEP AT UC AND
WERE PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
HOW THOSE REASONS MAY DIFFER BY
RACE.
GENDER AND ETHNICITY.
PUBLISHED BROWN IS LET YOU KNOW
THAT THE UNIVERSITY IS PUTTING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES INTO THIS
WORK.
AS WELL AS OTHER ESTABLISHED AND
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS WE HOPE AS
WELL THAT THE STATE WILL
CONTINUE TO CEDE OUR EFFORTS AS
YOU HAVE FOR THE LAST THREE
YEARS.
THIS IS SENT A POWERFUL MESSAGE
OF YOUR PRIORITIES TO OUR
LEADERS FACULTY AND STUDENTS AND
POTENTIAL FACULTY AND STUDENTS
THAT WE WANT TO LEAD THE WAY.
ON THIS ISSUE IN THIS COUNTRY
HEAR FROM US AGAIN SOON WE HAVE
TWO REPORTS COMING TO YOU BY
DECEMBER FIRST ABOUT THE SECOND
YEAR A FINAL REPORT ON SET THE
RESULTS IN A PRELIMINARY REPORT
ON YOUR THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE THE ADDITION WE
HAD ASSEMBLY MEMBER FREDDIE
RODRIGUEZ HERE WITH US --
FOR A BIT AND WELCOME --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN MCCARTY
HERE TODAY --
THIS AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US --
MY REACTION --
IN THE CITY OF RIVERSIDE THAT I
REPRESENT BY SOMETIME HAVE THE
OCCASION TO VISIT.
THE RIVERSIDE GREATER CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
AND WHEN I GO THERE TO THE
RIVERSIDE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
OF IT'S A ROOM NOT.
LIVE IT'S SMALLER THAN THIS BUT
THE PAST PRESIDENTS OF THE
RIVERSIDE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
PICTURES ARE ON THAT WALL.
WHEN I GO VISIT?
AND I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW
MANY DIFFERENT PRESIDENTS THE
GREATER RIVERSIDE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HAVE HAD [inaudible]
BUT SAY THERE'S FIFTY THERE ARE
FIFTY WHITE MEN.
EXCUSE ME FORTY NINE WHITE MEN
ON THAT WALL.
WHEN I GO VISIT?
THIS MORNING.
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE AN
EIGHT YEAR OLD CONSTITUENT WHO
CELEBRATED HIS BIRTHDAY AND HE
CHOSE TO CELEBRATE HIS BIRTHDAY
HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
SO I TOOK HIM TO THE FLOOR OF
THE ASSEMBLY.
HE WAS VERY INTERESTED IN THE
HISTORY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO I PROCEEDED TO
SHOW HIM.
THE PICTURES OF THE SPEAKERS OF
THE HOUSE OF THE SPEAKERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY GOING BACK.
TO EIGHTEEN FIFTY I NOTICED
SOMETHING.
ABOUT THOSE PICTURES.
I NOTICED THAT IF WE GO BACK.
TO EIGHTEEN FIFTY IN ALL THERE
WERE WHITE MEN ONE WHITE MAN
AFTER ANOTHER.
TELL WE GET TO MORE --
CURRENT TIMES IN OF NINETEEN
SIXTIES NINETEEN SEVENTIES
EIGHTIES.
THINGS START TO CHANGE.
AND WE SEE --
AFRICAN AMERICAN --
SPEAKER THE HOUSE LATINO
SPEAKERS OF THE HOUSE.
IT IS GONNA BE ALMOST FIFTY
YEARS.
THAT I GRADUATED FROM UC
RIVERSIDE THAT FIGURE THAT YEAR
IS APPROACHING RAPIDLY THAT IT
WILL BE FIFTY YEARS THAT I
GRADUATED FROM UC RIVERSIDE.
AND IN THOSE FIFTY YEARS.
WHEN I GO TO THE CAMPUSES AND
VISIT THE CAMPUSES WHETHER IT'S
UCLA?
UC RUBBER SAID UC SAN DIEGO UC
SANTA BARBARA UC RIVERSIDE.
I SEE AS IS INDICATED IN THIS
REPORT.
THAT THE STUDENT BODY HAS
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY.
WHEN THEY WERE ALMOST?
KNOW THAT THE NO STUDENTS AT
UCLA AS EARLY AS THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES.
RIGHT LATINO STUDENTS ARE
BEGINNING TO BE THE MAJORITY.
OF THE STUDENT BODY.
IN IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO AS THE STUDENT BODY HAS
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY.
THE PICTURES ON THE WALL OF THE
FACULTY REMAINED VERY MUCH THE
SAME AS THE PICTURES AND THAT
RAIDER RIVERSIDE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
AND IF YOU SEE [inaudible]
VALUES --
WHAT WE SAID OUR IS DIVERSITY
FOR THE REASONS THAT WE'VE
OUTLINED HERE --
IT'S HARD FOR ME.
IT IS DIFFICULT FOR ME TO SIT
HERE FIFTY YEARS LATER WHEN I
WAS A STUDENT --
ENTERING COLLEGE IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND HEAR FROM
AS FAR SEE THAT IT WAS HARD FOR
HER WHO IS A MUCH YOUNGER PERSON.
TO SEE A FACULTY DIVERSITY OF
FACULTY WHEN SHE WAS A STUDENT I
HAVE IN FRONT OF ME THE FIGURES.
GOING BACK.
TO NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR A
FIGURES FOR YOUR UC FOR BOTH
TENURE AND NON TENURED FACULTY.
AND AS I LOOK DOWN HERE ICY
GOING BACK TO NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR AFRICAN AMERICAN.
TENURE NON TENURED FACULTY EIGHT
UC WAS 2% IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR LATINO
CHICANO FACULTY WAS 5%.
SO THAT'S NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR I
GO ACROSS.
ALL THE WAY OVER HERE.
220-001-32000.
FOURTEEN AFRICAN AMERICAN
FACULTY IN THE FIGURES THAT I
HAVE HERE ACTUALLY WENT DOWN.
ACTUALLY WENT DOWN FROM 2% 21%
ACROSS UC.
LATINO FACULTY IN THAT SAME TIME
FROM NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE WENT UP.
FROM 5%.
THE 8%.
OVER A FORTY YEAR SPAN
[inaudible]
SO.
DOCTOR BROWN WELL YOU SAY WHY
NOT [inaudible]
I'M REMINDED.
OF MARTIN LUTHER KING WHO TALKED
ABOUT [inaudible]
HAVING PATIENTS.
MY PATIENCE IS RUNNING OUT.
LIVE PATIENCE IS RUNNING OUT AND
AND ALSO YOU KNOW I I I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS.
AND THE MONEY THAT THOSE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS ALLOCATED
BUT IF THIS IS YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'VE DONE.
IF THIS IS WHAT WE'VE DONE ALI.
SIT SIT HERE AND I'M NOT.
VERY OPTIMISTIC.
AND AYE AYE AYE AYE PASSED AND I
AM.
ACTUALLY MENTIONED.
GONNA ASK HIM.
THE SAME QUESTION THE SPEAKER
BETTIS REBEL REGION BETTERS
ASKED AT THE LAST REGION'S
MEETING.
THAT AT THE RATE WE'RE GOING NOW.
THE RATE WE'RE GOING NOW.
HOW LONG WILL THAT TAKE IS TO
HAVE THE FACULTY TO REFLECT THE
STUDENT BODY?
A HUNDRED YEARS.
IF WE USE THAT.
THAT THAT KIND RATE --
ARE HOW TO AND AND AND I'M I'M
MIGHT ACT MIGHT BE OVERLY
GENEROUS.
SO OUR I I THINK --
ARE WHAT THE I WOULD.
SAY TO ONE FOR FIRST OF ALL THE
OVERALL PICTURE.
I AM NOT DISPUTING [inaudible]
AND WOULDN'T.
I'M HAPPY FOR THIS KIND HEARING
AND I'M HAPPY FOR LEGISLATORS
LOOK AT LATERS FOCUS ON THE I DO
WANT TO INDICATE THAT
PERCENTAGES DON'T TELL THE WHOLE
STORY.
YOU HAVE TO ALSO LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS BECAUSE THE BASE IS
DIFFERENT WE HAVE TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND FACULTY NOW.
SO SOUL EVE IS SOLD WOULD BE A
PERCENT INCREASES ON A ON A
BIGGER BASE SO IT DOES SHOW SOME
SOME GROWTH.
BUT THE FUNDAMENTAL PICTURE
DON'T HERE DON'T HEAR ME ARGUING
ABOUT IT I AGREE.
OUR INTER THE FUNDAMENTAL
PICTURE.
NOW I DO THINK WE HAVE.
AS I SAID BEFORE I'LL SAY IT
AGAIN I THINK WE HAVE A
GENERATION OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE
THIS.
THERE'S BEEN PENT UP NEED TO
HIRE.
FOR WE HAVE PROCESSES WE HAVE
POLICIES AND WE ARE PRACTICES IN
PLACE THAT WITH THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HIRE MORE FRANKLY WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY YOU REALLY RAPIDLY
DIVERSIFY.
THE PARTNERSHIP THAT WE HAVE HAD
A WITH THE STATE WITH RESPECT TO
THAT THAT THAT TO ME PERCENT.
PER YEAR IF WE CAN JUST STRENGTH
OF THAT PARTNERSHIP AND ENABLED
US TO HIRE FACULTY AT AT AT OUT
GIVEN ALSO THE AGING OF THE
FACULTY THAT WE HAVE.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RAPIDLY CHANGE THE PICTURE --
IN A RELATIVELY SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME I WOULD LOVE TO SEE IT --
ARE OUT OF OUR VESSEL OUT WHAT
I'D SAY ABOUT THAT SUSAN DO YOU
HAVE ANYTHING --
TO I WOULD ALSO SAY WE CAN'T
DISPUTE THE NUMBERS THAT YOU
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU AND WERE
DISAPPOINTED BY THEM AS WELL.
IT DOES FEEL THOUGH WITH THE
PARTICULARLY WITH THIS PROGRAM
WHERE YOU HAVE PUT YOUR
COMMITMENTS ON THE LINE.
THAT IT HAS CREATED A NEW SENSE
OF URGENCY AND IT'S WE TRULY
HAVE A NEW PRACTICES GOING ON IN
WAYS -- WE
WERE ALL PREPARED FOR BUT THE
MONEY MAKES A DIFFERENCE AND
THEN WE SAY --
OF WHEN I THINK WASN'T
GENERATION OPPORTUNITY LOOK
WE'RE LEGISLATORS IT LATER AS
ARE AT YOUR HAVING THIS HEARING
ON YOU SEE FACULTY DIVERSITY HAS
THAT HAPPENED.
FOR EUROPE BESIDES THE THE
PRESENTATION WOULD IMAGINE THAT
IT HAS FOR OKAY BUT PRIOR YOU
KNOW THIS IS IN RECENT YEARS.
WE'VE GOT REGIONS THAT ARE
DEDICATED TO THIS ISSUE.
WHICH I WOULD I SERVED IN IN MY
BROTHER'S CAPACITY AS CHAIR OF
THE ACADEMIC SENATE COMMITMENT
FROM THE REGION'S AT THAT TIME --
OUT THIS PRESIDENT HAS GONE
BEYOND BEYOND LIP SERVICE TO THE
DEDICATION OF OF DIVERSITY.
HOW WE HAVE HAD WHICH I DIDN'T
SHARE MY LITTLE PRESENTATION WE
HAVE HAD CHANCE L'OREAL
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT FACULTY
DIVERSITY WE HAVE HAD AND I I
SIT WITH THE EEVEE SEES --
OUT LACHESIS IT WITH BOTH OF THE
AT HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM IN
TERMS OF THEIR PROGRAMS THE
DEDICATION ALONG THESE LINES WE
HAVE NOW THIS PATHWAYS FOR WHICH
THERE IS.
A COMING TOGETHER OF A GREAT
DEAL OF FOCUS ON THIS.
YEAH I I I WOULDN'T A DISPUTE
ARGUES THAT THE PROGRAMS THAT
THERE ARE.
PROGRAMS IN PLACE TO HELP THE
NUMBERS GROW.
BUT IN THE AND AND AND AND I
THINK THOSE PROGRAMS OR OR OR
WITH WHILE.
AND WE'RE SUPPORTING.
BUT WHEN I SIT DOWN [inaudible]
AT AT COCO'S IN THE MORNING.
WITH --
AFRICAN AMERICAN MEN AND WE AS
OLDER.
MEN TALK ABOUT.
THE UC AND HIGHER EDUCATION.
WE WE SEE WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE TODAY.
AND AND I GUESS THAT IT THAT
CONTRASTS WITH SO MUCH AND SO
STARKLY.
WITH OTHER WITH OTHER WITH OTHER
SEGMENTS OF EMPLOYMENT OR YOU
KNOW YOU IT THEN THE IN THE IN
THE FILL.
OF PAT BROWN THEY SHOW A
LEGISLATURE ITSELF THAT THE
LEGISLATOR.
IN THE EARLY NINETEEN SIXTIES
AGAIN.
IN A PREDOMINATELY WHITE MEN.
LOOK AT THE CHANGE THAT HAS COME
ABOUT AND SINCE THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES TO TODAY YEAH AND THE
COMPOSITION OF THE LEGISLATURE
BUT WHY IS IT THAT A HIGHER
EDUCATION.
LAGS SO MUCH AND I I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK AND BRING OUT A COUPLE OF
THINGS YOU KNOW I I HEARD.
ABOUT THE RECRUIT I HEARD ABOUT
APPLYING ONLINE.
BUT I ALSO HEARD JUST IN MY
COMMUNITY [inaudible]
RIVERSIDE [inaudible] TO PHD.
ONE AS RECENT AS YESTERDAY AND
ANOTHER PHD --
GENTLEMAN BOTH LATINA.
WHO I'VE KNOWN FOR A VERY LONG
TIME --
FIRST ONE IS THE FIRST ONE IS
NOW TEACHING AT UC RIVERSIDE.
HE SAID THAT HE WAS ONLY HIRED
IN HIS FOURTH ATTEMPT.
AT UC RIVERSIDE.
THAT HE HE TAUGHT [inaudible]
AT THE AND WHY YOU.
HE TAUGHT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
TEXAS.
BOTH OF THOSE IN THAT ORDER
BEFORE COMING TO UC ARE BUT THAT
HE APPLIED FOR TIMES.
DO YOU SEE OUR DIDN'T EVEN GET
INTERVIEWED.
IN IN ONE OF THE ATTEMPTS.
IT IS THE SAME THAT I HEAR FROM
MY FRIEND.
UP WITH ANOTHER PHD.
APPLYING TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND CAT GET AN INTERVIEW
CANNOT GET INTERVIEWED.
THEY'RE NOT EVEN LAST SO.
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT THAT THAT
COME TO MIND [inaudible]
WITHIN UC.
THAT I HEAR.
THAT WERE IN THAT INTERVIEW
PROCESS AND TRYING TO BECOME
FACULTY.
THE DEPARTMENTS ARE SO NARROW.
IN WHAT THEY ARE LOOKING.
FOR OR THAT THEY PERPETUATE.
THE PRACTICE OF WHAT THEY ARE
ARE ALREADY DOING.
SO THEY LOOK FOR PHD WHO ARE
DOING.
IT SEEMS TO ME AND I AM NOT A
PHD EXACTLY THE SAME KIND OF
WORK THAT THEY ARE DOING.
USING THE SAME METHODOLOGY THAT
THEY ARE USING.
AND ARE NOT OPEN.
ARE NOT OPEN TO DIFFERENCES.
AND I I WOULD SAY THAT BOTH OF
THOSE THINGS NEED TO CHANGE OR
ELSE WE'RE GONNA HAVE FIFTY
YEARS DOWN THE LINE.
THE SAME DISCUSSION AS WE ARE
HAVING NOW [inaudible]
AND AND THAT THAT THAT HAS TO BE
FRUSTRATING. TO CANDIDATES.
THAT HAS TO BE OF FRESH STATING
TO STUDENTS --
BECAUSE WE ARE PRODUCING PH DAYS.
BUT IF THEY ARE NOT DOING
EXACTLY THAT KIND OF WORK.
THAT THE COMMITTEE OR THE
DEPARTMENT IS LOOKING FOR THEY
DON'T GET HIRED --
MR MCCARTY.
YES THANK YOU --
FIRST OF ALL AT THANKS FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING I KNOW WE
HAD A JOINT HEARING.
WITH THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
HIGHER AT TWO YEARS AGO ON THE
SAME TOPIC SO IT IS.
AN IMPORTANT CONVERSATION AND AS
MR MEDINA MENTION WE HAVE COULD
REMAIN THE BUDGET IN THIS ISSUE
FOR THREE YEARS IN A ROW.
AND YOU YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T JUST
THROW MONEY AROUND AND IS
EXPECTED THINGS TO HAPPEN BUT WE
WE CERTAINLY WANT.
TO ADDRESSES BECAUSE IT DOES
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THE
PERCEPTION WHEN STUDENTS GO THE
CLASSROOMS AND SEE WHO'S
TEACHING THEM YOU KNOW RESEARCH
SHOWS US BY WERE TRYING TO GET.
OR ETHNIC STUDIES FROM OUR
COLLEGES DOWN THERE ARE HIGH
SCHOOLS IT REALLY DOES MAKE IT A
DIFFERENCE IN IN STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT SO --
YOU KNOW WE DON'T REALLY DON'T
HAVE TIME TO WAIT AND ONE ISSUES
THAT IS IMPORTANT IS THAT IT
I'VE TIME.
HAPPENING BECAUSE THERE'S A
GENERATION OF PEOPLE GONNA
RETIRE.
ITSELF THERE'S A WAVE OF THESE
BOOMERS BUT EVERYONE A COLUMN.
IN THIS COHORT AGAIN RETIRED.
AND IF YOU GET IT WRONG YOU LOCK
IT IF THERE FORTY YEARS LIKE.
IT'S LIKE PUT RED CAP ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
BAD ANALOGY THERE BUT YES BUT
IT'S A IT'S A YOU KNOW
POTENTIALLY AT THIRTY FORTY
FIFTY YEAR --
TEN YOUR POSITION SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE GET --
THAT YOU KNOW PEOPLE IN THE
POSITION THAT REFLECT --
CALIFORNIA SO THERE IS IMPORTANT
AND THAT'S WHY I REALLY WANT TO
HEAR.
THE NEXT PANEL WE GET TO THAT AS
FAR AS WHAT'S HAPPENING.
AT THE CAMPUS LEVEL AND WHAT
WE'RE DOING WITH THOSE RESOURCES
WE PUT IN BUT I WANT TO ASK I
WANT TO GO UP TO ONE SPECIFIC
THING BECAUSE SOME OF THESE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
IS KIND OF THE CHICKEN THAT WHAT
COMES FIRST YOU LOOK AT THE
NUMBER OF THAT. FOR EXAMPLE
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS WHO
ARE HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES WHO
ARE UCL'S WILL GO ON THE UC IT'S
A IT'S A NUMBER THAT'S VERY VERY
LONG.
EMBARRASSING IS.
LESS WAY LESSENED BY PRESENTING
IS THREE PER EXAMPLE THAT CO
WORKER EVEN THAT TINO --
ACT ECONOMICS PHD IS NOT THAT
GREAT SO THEY'RE PROBABLY IN
HIGH DEMAND.
IT'S LIKE A HIGHLY COVETED.
START BUT ALL QUARTERBACK OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT SORT OF
THEIR WHO RECRUITED BY.
ALL THESE COLLEGES WHAT HAVE YOU
AND THEY CAN THEY CAN PICK SO.
I ASSUME THAT WE HAVE THE SAME
CHALLENGES WE'RE WE'RE GOING
AFTER.
INDIVIDUALS WHO CAN CHECK IN AND
CHIU SO IF WE DO --
LET'S SAY WIN THE PRIZE AND AND
GET SOME SOME GREAT TALENT THAT
SOME OF OUR NINE UC'S AN
UNDERGRADUATE UC'S.
DO WE HAVE A CHALLENGE AND
SOMETHING AND KEEPING THEM IT IS
THAT'S ISSUE TO IS NOT JUST.
RECRUITMENT RETENTION SO.
HOW DOES HOW DOES THAT HOW'S
THAT PLAYING OUT WOULD WHEN WE
HAVE BEEN MAKING A DIFFERENCE
AND IN AND FINING PEOPLE TELLING
HIS POSITIONS AND?
AND KEEPING THEM WITHIN THE
UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA.
WE DO HAVE --
A CHALLENGE IN RETENTION BOTH
BECAUSE AS YOU SAID --
THE PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT
HAVE OTHER OPTIONS.
AND BECAUSE SOMETIMES THEY'RE IN
ENVIRONMENTS DON'T FEEL THEY CAN
DO THEIR BEST WORK AND THEY
LEAVE BECAUSE OF THAT.
SO WE HAVE STARTED A SYSTEM WIDE --
TO GATHER INFORMATION ABOUT
FACULTY WHO LEAVE.
A AND IN PARTICULAR WE HAVE
STARTED TO DO THIS BECAUSE WE
WANT TO SEE --
WHAT DIFFERENCE IS THERE MIGHT
BE BY RACE AND BY GENDER --
AND THE NEW PROGRAM THAT THAT
JANET A PRE YES I'M SORRY YEAH
AND AND THIS YEAR FOR THE FIRST
TIME WE ARE PUTTING SOME OF THIS
IS THE PRESIDENT'S MONEY.
INTO PILOTS --
ON RETENTION.
AND RECRUITMENT IS ONLY HALF THE
STORY -- AND
AND IF WE CAN'T KEEP THE AD MORE
DIVERSE FACULTY OR HIRING WE ARE --
NEVER CAN HAVE THE KIND OF
PROGRESS THAT WE WANT AND SO
THAT THE SIX CAMPUSES HAVE.
OF MONEY THIS YEAR TO DO AND
THEY'VE DESIGN PROGRAMS THEY'VE
GOT FACULTY ALREADY AT WORK ON
FIGURING OUT HOW TO MAKE THEIR
ENVIRONMENTS --
THE RIGHT ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL
THE FACULTY IN THEIR DEPARTMENT
INCLUDING WOMEN AND
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITIES AND
WHAT WE'RE THINKING ABOUT --
ALSO OB BROADER CLIMATE ISSUES --
ARE THAT THAT MOST OF US
RECOGNIZE THAT WHEN YOU BRING A
NONTRADITIONAL PEOPLE INTO AN
ENVIRONMENT PARTICULAR
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THERE ARE.
LOTS OF NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS
THESE NONTRADITIONAL PERSONS
THEY GET SWAMPED BY THE OUR OB
AT FOR GOOD REASONS FOR GOOD
REASONS --
AND AND ARE A CHAIR MEDINA YOU
YOU HAD A CONVERSATION WITH THE
EARLIER PANEL ABOUT --
HIGH.
INVOLVEMENT IN ACADEMIC SENATE
WHICH IS A VOLUNTEER ACTIVITY
YOU YOU WILL FIND THEN THOSE
THOSE PERSONS OF COLOR AND WOMEN
WHO ARE FACULTY HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION ABOUT HOW THEY SPEND
THEIR TIME --
MOST OF THEM ARE TRYING TO
ADVANCE THEMSELVES IN THEIR
CAREER BUT MANY OF THEM FEEL AN
OBLIGATION TO ADDRESS THE NEED.
FOR THEIR MENTORSHIP FOR AND FOR
THEIR SUPPORT IN THE LIVES OF
THOSE STUDENTS.
THAT IS TIME CONSUMING ARE AND
FOR SOME OF THEM THEY MAKE A
DECISION TO DO THAT THAN TO BE
ENGAGED AND THE GOVERNMENT'S
ACTIVITIES ASSOCIATED WITH
ACADEMIC SENATE.
IN MY PARTICULAR CASE I SERVED
IN THE ACADEMIC SENATE --
BUT I WAS A MEMBER NOT OF AN
UNDERGRADUATE PROGRAM WAS A
MEMBER OF A GRADUATE PROGRAM.
THE STUDENT A DIFFERENT.
RESEARCH DEMANDS ARE ARE JUST
THE SAME FOR THE FACULTY BUT THE
THE STUDENT A MAN'S ARE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT AND I CHOSE TO SERVE
THE NEEDS OF ACCESS AND
MENTORSHIP AND SALSA.
FOR BY INVOLVING MYSELF IN
ADMISSIONS WORK.
THE ACADEMIC SENATE'S COMMITTEE
ON ON EMISSIONS WAS MY WAY OF
DOING.
BUT I I I I I I GUESS I WANTED
TO SAY I APPRECIATED THAT
EARLIER CONVERSATION WE DO NEED
TO ADDRESS CRIME ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH SUPPORTING.
THE LIVES OF THE NONTRADITIONAL
PERSONS WE DO BRING INTO THESE
ROLES.
BACK THE ONE MARKED MADE YOU
COULD ANSWER THIS BRIEFLY SO.
YOU KNOW THIS IS ALL TALK UP
HERE AND THEN PRACTICES IN.
ON THE GROUNDS AT THESE. NINE
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES.
SO AS WE HAVE THIS WAVE OF
PEOPLE --
RETIRING WHAT IS THAT WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN FILLINGS
POSITIONS AND HOW CAN WE BE
ASSURED THAT AS MR MEDINA SAID
WE DON'T GO BACK AND LOOK TWENTY
YEARS FROM NOW AND SAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT TO THE IN QUITE
WORK OUT FEES.
OUR ARE HIGH THAT THAT IS WHY BY
THE WAY I HOPE.
THERE IS AB DISK THIS COMMITTEE
FOR THE SAKE OF THIS OF THE THE
SERVICE THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SUPPOSED TO RENDER TO
STATE I ACTUALLY SUPPORT.
THIS KIND OF FOCUS ON AN ONGOING
BASIS THAT'S NUMBER ONE WE WANT
TO DO IT AND THE CAMPUSES ARE
DOING IT ONGOING BASIS TO THE
PRESIDENT HAS YEARLY FOCUS ON
THESE VERY ISSUES AS WELL WE ARE
ONLY THE ACCOUNTABILITY MAKE
HOUSE TOM.
OR A PROCESS ARE BOTH.
BECAUSE WE WANT OUTCOME RESULT
YES AN HOUR ACT WE BE ASSURED
THAT WILL WILL BE CONFIDENT THAT
WHAT SEATED.
IT WHAT I WOULD SAY IS OUT OF
FIRST OF ALL YOU YOU SHOULD AT
HERE US PRESENT ON TWO FRONTS.
BOTH IN TERMS OF THE OUTCOMES
AND ALSO IN TERMS OF THE PROCESS
THESE THAT WE PUT IN PLACE TO
ATTAIN THOSE OUTCOMES.
YOU YOU MAY NOT BE ABLE TO KNOW
HOW HOW FUNCTIONAL THOSE
PROCESSES ARE BUT YOU CAN JUST
OUTCOMES BUT BY ATTENDING TO THE
PROCESS THESE AS WELL IT HOW IT
INDICATES THAT YOU HAVE AN
INTEREST BY HOWELL WE EFFECT
THESE CHANGES.
WE OURSELVES AS PART OF THOSE
PROCESSES OUGHT TO HAVE WITH OUR
ACCOUNTABILITY MECHANISMS THAT
WE CAN ARTICULATE FOR YOU TOO
BECAUSE THE ISSUE IS THAT
SHARON'S RIGHT.
AT LEAST THAT'S WHAT HOW I I
HEAR YOU ARE --
OUR OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER OUT OF
HIGH A MCCARTY --
YOU WANT TO HAVE ASSURANCE THE
OTHER THING IS --
I I I WOULD INVITE YOU. TO TO
PARTICIPATE WITH US IN ANY WAY
YOU WOULD SEE FIT OFF SOME OF
OUR A AND SOME OF OUR
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'RE HAVING
ON OUR CAMPUSES.
AROUND THESE ISSUES --
WHEN YOU LOOK AS AS AS CHAIR
MEDINA SAID SO WELL AT THE
HISTORY IT IS HARD TO TRUST OUR
PRESIDENT IN OUR FUTURE?
BUT HOW DO YOU BUILD TRUST IF
YOU DON'T BUILD THE LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY IN THE LEVEL OF
ENGAGEMENT --
AND AND I AM INTERESTED IN AND
AND WHATEVER WE COULD DO TO
BETTER EFFECT.
MR MCCARTY.
I'D I DON'T THINK THAT YOU HAVE
IN OUR PACKET WHAT WAS PRESENTED
TO THE REGIONS.
THAT MULTI COLORED --
WITH THAT LOOKING AT AT HIRES I
THINK.
TRYING TO LOOK AT THE YEARS.
AGAIN.
THIS.
ONE YOU SEE LATTER RANKIN
FACULTY HIRES BY RACE AND
ETHNICITY.
GOES. 848-522-0009 TWO THOUSAND
TEN I THINK THAT'S THE ONE THAT
YOU PRESENTED TO THE REGENTS AND
IN THEIR THE SEGMENT WITH THE
MOLE STE GROWTH.
IN NEW FACULTY HIRES DO YOU
REMEMBER.
OF PROSE BROWN WOULD SEGMENT
THAT WAS IT WAS FOREIGN BORN.
AND YEAH YEAH IT AND AND IT WAS.
MUCH HIGHER THAN ANY OTHER
CATEGORY --
BY A LOT.
BY BY A WIDE MARGIN --
NO I I I COME.
FROM IMMIGRANT PARENTS.
YEAH MY FATHER WAS NOT BORN IN
THIS COUNTRY I I WAS --
BUT BUT THERE I THINK THAT THAT
SHOWS KIND OF A YOU KNOW I I
GUESS I COULD REFER TO IT IT IS
ALMOST.
A TENSION.
BETWEEN TRYING TO GROW
[inaudible]
OUR OWN [inaudible]
HOME GROWN [inaudible]
FACULTY.
AND IT WHEN I THINK WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT G. CONNELL LAND NEXT TO
GONNA LATINO --
AFRICAN AMERICAN WE WE ARE
LOOKING AT FACULTY.
FROM THIS COUNTRY THAT'S A AND
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE DATA A
COUPLE --
WENT WIN WIN I LOOK AT THE DATA
CHICANO LATINO WE'RE NOT
INCLUDING A RIGHT WE'RE NOT
INCLUDING IF YOU CAME FROM SOUTH
AMERICA OR WORD IT IS WE ALL PUT
TOGETHER.
TOPIC.
I'M SORRY WE DECIDED ABOUT SIX
YEARS AGO TO DISAGGREGATED THOSE
TWO GROUPS SO THAT WE CAN TRACK
DOMESTIC --
LITEON X. FACULTY AND
INTERNATIONAL BECAUSE WE THOUGHT
WE WERE MASKING THINGS IF WE DID
IF WE DIDN'T RECOGNIZE LET ME
ASK THE QUESTION WHAT WHAT WHY
DO WE SEE.
IS THERE ANY YOU KNOW WHAT
EXPLANATION IS THERE FOR YOU
KNOW WHY WHY SUCH A A RAPID
GROWTH.
OF FACULTY COMING.
BEING FLETCHER A TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU I WAS SURPRISED WHEN I
SAW THAT --
TO MAYBE MAYBE SAYS GOOD SPEAK
MORE TO IT BECAUSE I HAVE NOT
STUDIED THE WIVES OF THAT I KNOW
WITH CERTAIN STEM AREAS --
AWARE OF MOST OF THE CAMPUS HAS
BEEN GROWING MORE RAPIDLY I
COULD SEE WHY THAT MIGHT HAVE
HAPPENED SUSAN DO YOU KNOW MORE.
WE DO IT IT'S AN INDICATION THAT
WE WE RECRUIT INTERNATIONALLY --
AND THAT THAT'S APPROPRIATE BE
SURE WE WE HAVE A SENSE OF THE
FULL.
UP POOL OF APPLICANTS --
I THINK THE PERCENTAGE WENT UP
OVER THAT TIME ABOUT 4% BUT THAT
WAS A LARGER PERCENT THEN THE IT
THE INCREASE IN THE UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITY POPULATION.
SET SO WE AGREE WITH YOU THAT WE
WE WE'RE THAT IS OUT WE'RE NOT
PUTTING --
RESOURCES INTO THAT --
I IF I COULD.
THE AD REALLY AND AN ANSWER TO A
PREVIOUS QUESTION YOU ASKED --
I THINK WHEN I MOST ENCOURAGED
BY THERE'S A LOT TO NOT BE
ENCOURAGED BY WHICH WE'RE
HEARING YOU YOU ARE SHARE WITH
US.
I AM MOST ENCOURAGED BY THE FACT
THAT THESE PROGRAMS THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO SUPPORT FOR THIS
PROGRAM.
ARE FOCUSED ON HOW WE EVALUATE
CANDIDATES WHEN WE GET HUNDREDS
OF APPLICANTS WE HAVE TO HAVE A
GOOD WAY THAT'S NOT FULL OF BIAS --
TO FIGURE OUT WHO'S THE RIGHT
PERSON FOR YOU SEE NOT WHO'S THE
BEST PERSON IN THE WORLD HOWEVER
YOU MIGHT DETERMINE THAT THE
WHO'S THE RIGHT FACULTY. FOR YOU
SEE AT OUR FOR OUR FACULTY
MEMBERS HAVE --
SCENE THAT THEY CAN'T EVALUATE
AS YOU'VE SUGGESTED WE WILL HAVE
THE SAME RESULTS WE'VE HAD IN
THE PAST SO THEY ARE
EXPERIMENTING WITH.
RUBRICS THEY'RE EXPERIMENTING
WITH -- A
PRIORITIZATION OF CONTRIBUTIONS
TO DIVERSITY STATEMENTS FROM ALL
CANDIDATES.
AND IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE WHEN
YOU INTERVENE IN A PROCESS --
LIKE EVALUATION.
I AND I I I DO WANT OF THE WHAT
WHAT YOU OF HER FROM US IS WHAT
WHAT WE ARE DOING TO TRY TO BEND
THE CURVE. TO CHANGE THE
REALITIES OF THAT ARE AS AS A
SOME WOMEN MCCARTY SAID THAT
FORTY TWO YEARS. THREE YEARS
DOWN THE LINE WE SHOW THAT WE
ACTUALLY DID SOMETHING HERE.
OB ARE THAT THAT WE DIDN'T
THROWN A GOOD MONEY AFTER BAD
THAT WE ACTUALLY TRIED TO AFFECT
A NEW AGENDA IN THE NEW REALITY --
ARE.
A MORE INCLUSIVE REALITY --
I I I THINK.
FROM MY CHAIR I HAVE NEVER SEEN
THE THE COMMITMENT SO REAL NOR
THE POLICIES AND PROCESS THESE
PUT IN PLACE TO THE DEGREE TO
WHICH WE HAVE --
I'D ACT --
I'M HAPPY CAN WE LEARN TO DO
THIS EVEN BETTER FOR EXAMPLE THE
REALITY DID CHIU JUST A ONE OF
YOU JUST IDENTIFIED ABOUT.
OUT AND IT'S A REALITY THAT HAD
AT THAT AFFLICTS RESEARCH
UNIVERSITIES WHICH A LOT OF
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND POSITION UP
PROGRAMS A POSITION AT THE
FRONTIERS OF KNOWLEDGE.
THAT'S WHERE THEIR POSITION
THEY'RE NOT MAKING GENERAL
EDUCATION THEY'RE THEY'RE ALSO
GENERATING NEW KNOWLEDGE AND
THAT'S THAT THAT USUALLY IS A
COMPLY WITH SOME.
HYPER DIVERSIFICATION THAT
HAPPENS AT THOSE FRONT TWO YEARS.
AND SOMETIMES WHAT HAPPENS IS
THEY HIRE NISH SPECIALISTS.
WHICH WHICH MAKES IT ACTUALLY
Và HARDER TO GET DIVERSITY.
BUT WHAT YOU ALSO FIND BECAUSE
AND FACULTY FINING THIS THAT
BECAUSE THE FRONTIERS OF
KNOWLEDGE OF CHANGING MORE
RAPIDLY.
VERIFY THE ACTUALLY DOES GREATER
VALUE IN HAVING MORE GENERALISTS.
IN THEIR DEPARTMENTS AND THAT
ACTUALLY WILL HELP OUT WITH WITH
THE VERSE AT DIVERSIFYING THE
DEPARTMENT SO YOU IDENTIFIED
RIGHT PHENOMENA THE RIGHT WAY TO
ATTACK IT.
I'M NOT SAYING WE'VE WE'VE HIT
UPON -- BUT
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO FIND IT
[inaudible]
WELL.
I THANK YOU BOTH.
I KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS.
OF BECAUSE THIS IS A MATTER OF
GREAT IMPORTANCE --
TO STUDENTS TO THE REGION'S AND
TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR THANK YOU
FOR BEING WITH US THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WITH
THAT WILL TRANSITION TO OUR
THIRD PANEL WHICH WILL FOCUS ON
CAMPUS BASED EFFORTS TO
IMPROVING.
OF FACULTY DIVERSITY.
WE HAVE WITH US TODAY.
THE VICE PROVOST FOR ACADEMIC
PERSONNEL AT UC RIVERSIDE.
I'M A WALKER.
THE VICE PROVOST FOR ACADEMIC
EQUITY DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
FROM UC IRVINE.
DOUGLAS HAYNES.
AND THE ASSOCIATE VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR ACADEMIC
DIVERSITY.
AT UC DAVIS TRACK AS A DONOR.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE WITH US.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
I AM OF COURSE FROM MISTER
CHAIRMAN'S ALMA MATER AND I'VE
JUST HEARD SOME THINGS THAT HE'S
NOT SO HAPPY ABOUT IT RIVERSIDE
BUT HOPEFULLY.
I CAN EXPLAIN TO YOU SOME THINGS
THAT WE'RE DOING THAT I THINK A
VERY POSITIVE --
AS YOU'RE WELL AWARE --
RIVERSIDE HAS A HIGHLY
DIVERSIFIED UNDERGRADUATE BODY
THAT 45% OF THE UNDERGRADUATES
AS OF THE FALL OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN IDENTIFIED AS
BELONGING TO AN UNDER
REPRESENTED GROUP [inaudible]
BUT ALSO GIVEN THE WHAT WE'VE
BEEN HEARING TODAY AND YOU KNOW
THAT THE DIVERSITY AMONG THE
FACULTY --
LAGS WAY BEHIND THAT --
AND THE A IN LATE. TWENTY
FOURTEEN THE BEGINNING OF THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN ACADEMIC YEAR --
THERE WAS --
A BIG PUSH ON OUR CAMPUS TO
REALLY TRY TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT AND I MIGHT POSE IT --
A RESPONSE TO ONE OF YOUR
EARLIER ABOUT WHY WE MOVE SO
SLOWLY I THINK SOMETIMES WE MODE
MOVE SLOWLY AND ACADEMIA BECAUSE
WERE USED TO ALSO CAN QUIT.
VERY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS.
AND THEN ON THE BASIS OF THE
RESULTS OF THAT THEN ASKING THE
NEXT SPECIFIC QUESTION AND I'M A
SCIENTIST AND THAT'S THE WAY
SCIENCE WORKS.
HOWEVER --
CERTAINLY FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
WHEN I TOOK ON THIS POSITION
WHICH WAS EXACTLY DURING THAT
PERIOD OF TIME I THOUGHT I DON'T
WANT TO DO.
A WHOLE BUNCH A LITTLE
EXPERIMENT SO WHAT I WANT US TO
DO IS OUR VERY BEST WITH ALL OF
OUR BEST IDEAS AND SEE IF WE CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
SO I'M GOING TO TELL YOU ABOUT
THE DIFFERENCE THAT WE'VE MADE.
I CAN TELL YOU WHAT WE DID DO
BUT I CAN'T TELL YOU EXACTLY
WHICH ONE OF THOSE ACTUALLY
BECAUSE THE DIFFERENCE AND MAYBE
IT WAS A GOOD COMBINATION OF ALL
OF THEM.
SO IT'S NOT A GOOD EXPERIMENT IS
VERY POOR SCIENCE BUT NEVER THE
LESS I THINK WE'VE ACHIEVED WHAT
WE WERE TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
SO INYO PACKETS YOU HAVE A HAND
OUT THAT --
INCLUDES.
A GRAPH HERE ON THE FIRST PAGE.
AND WE INSTITUTED THE A NUMBER
OF INITIATIVES WHERE THE RED
ARROW IS WHICH IS BETWEEN THE
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN AND FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN ACADEMIC YEAH.
AND BEFORE WE GET INTO.
WHAT IT IS --
THAT WE ACTUALLY DID I THOUGHT
IT WOULD BE GOOD TO LOOK AT THE
THE RESULTS [inaudible]
BEFORE --
THESE INTERVENTIONS IN THE THREE
YEARS BEFORE THESE INTERVENTIONS
THE INCOMING FACULTY WERE
BETWEEN SOMETHING LIKE 10213% OF
THE NW RECRUITS.
OFF TO THESE INTERVENTIONS WE
WENT UP TO ABOUT 22%.
THE FIRST YEAR WE THOUGHT WELL
THIS IS WONDERFUL IS THIS A ONE
OFF HAVE WE ACTUALLY DONE
SOMETHING SIGNIFICANT HERE.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE WE'VE MANAGED
TO REPLICATE THAT IN THE THREE
YEARS PAAS THE INTERVENTIONS SO
SO WE'VE ROUGHLY DOUBLED --
THE NUMBER OF UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITY FACULTY IN THE INCOMING
COHORT -- WE
IN THE FIRST YEAR DIDN'T HAVE
MUCH DIDN'T MAKE MUCH OF AN
IMPACT ON THAT THE NUMBER OF NEW
RECRUITS IDENTIFYING AS FEMALE
BUT AFTER A LITTLE BIT MORE
EFFORT.
TO THOSE WENT UP --
NOW FROM ABOUT. 353-637-2407
PERCENT OF THE INCOMING FACULTY
AND AGAIN THE FIRST YEAR WE WANT
SOCIAL THIS WAS REAL BUT NOW
WE'VE REPLICATED IT FOR A SECOND
YEAR SO WE THINK.
THAT WE'VE MADE SOME DIFFERENCES
IN THAT REGARD.
NOW WHAT DO WE DO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I THINK IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ON A CAMPUS
IS THAT THERE'S A STRONG
CONSISTENT MESSAGE FROM THE
LEADERSHIP.
AND THAT INCLUDES.
SORT OF PUTTING THEIR MONEY
WHERE THEIR MOUTH IS IN TERMS OF
LEADERSHIP AND AND I IT THAT'S
WHY I HAVE THIS COMPASS IT.
SET OF PHOTOGRAPHS FROM THE
LEADERSHIP AT THE UC CAMPUS
WHICH ARE CLEARLY ILLUSTRATES
THIS COMMITMENT TO AND THERE ARE --
40% OF OUR LEADERS WHO IDENTIFY
AS FEMALE AND ABOUT 25% WHO ARE
UNDER REPRESENTED --
TO FROM UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS.
ALSO EVERYWHERE YOU LOOK ON OUR
WEBSITE IT TALKS ABOUT --
THE IMPORTANCE OF DIVERSITY OUR
INTEREST IN HIRING A DIVERSE
FACULTY AND SO ON SO IT'S A
CONSISTENT.
PERSISTENT OP MESSAGE FROM THE
TOP.
THE SECOND THING WE DID WAS THAT
IN OUR HIRING ADVERTISEMENTS WE
PLACE TO VERY DELIBERATE --
SENTENCES --
ONE IS THAT YOU SEE ARE IS A
WORLD CLASS RESEARCH UNIVERSITY
WITH AN EXCEPTIONALLY DIVERSE
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT BODY.
ITS MISSION IS EXPLICITLY LINKED
TO PROVIDING ROUTES TO
EDUCATIONAL SUCCESS BALL UNDER
REPRESENTED IN FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENTS A COMMITMENT TO
THIS MISSION IS A PREFERRED
QUALIFICATIONS SO THIS GOES INTO
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF OUR
ADVERTISEMENTS FOR FACULTY JOBS.
THE SECOND THING THAT GOES IN IS --
A PHRASE THAT SAYS ADVANCEMENT
THROUGH THE FACULTY RANKS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS
THROUGH A SERIES OF STRUCTURED.
MERIT BASED EVALUATIONS
OCCURRING EVERY TWO TO THREE
YEARS EACH OF WHICH HAS
SUBSTANTIAL PIA INPUT.
I YOU MIGHT NOT IMMEDIATELY
IMAGINE WHY WE THOUGHT THIS
WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA.
BUT IF YOU.
IF YOU'RE EITHER TRADITIONAL.
UNIVERSITY AND YOU'VE DESCRIBED
THEM AS HAVING A LOT OF WHITE
MALE LEADERSHIP --
THEN THERE'S A TENDENCY AT MANY
UNIVERSITIES TO GET AHEAD.
BY WHO YOU KNOW WHO YOU PLAY
GOLF WITH WHO YOU INVITE TO
DINNER AND SO FORTH AND THAT'S
NOT ALWAYS COMFORTABLE FOR WOMEN
AND UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
FACULTY --
TO FOR TO PARTICIPATE AND I KNOW
IT CERTAINLY WASN'T FOR ME I
DIDN'T LIKE THAT APPROACH TO
LIFE AT OLE.
SO I WANTED TO GO TO A PLACE
JUDGED ON MY OWN ACCOMPLISHMENTS
AND JUDGE FROM MY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS BY MY PO'S
RATHER THAN OF THE CHAIR.
OF MY DEPARTMENT RATHER THAN THE
DEAN I PLAYED GOLF WITH THE
WHATEVER SO --
THAT'S WHY WE PUT THAT IN.
HI --
THIRDLY WE REQUIRED A
CONTRIBUTION TO DIVERSITY
STATEMENT FROM OLD JOB
CANDIDATES THIS IS TRUE FOR ALL
STAFF AS WELL AS A FACULTY --
BUT THIS WAS NEW AT THAT TIME
FOR THE FACULTY.
AND IN THAT STATEMENT WE ALSO
GAP WICCANS TO DESCRIBE THEIR
PASTA POTENTIAL FUTURE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO PROMOTING A
DIVERSE.
EQUITABLE AND INCLUSIVE
ENVIRONMENT WHICH IS A KEY
REQUIREMENT OF THE ROLE OF EVERY
FACULTY MEMBER AT UC OFF.
THERE ARE NUMEROUS WAYS TO
CONTRIBUTE AND A COMMITMENT TO
THIS PART OF OUR MISSION CAN BE
REFLECTED THROUGH RESEARCH
TEACHING SUPERVISION MENTORING
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT SERVICE AND
ANY OF THE OTHER VERY THE
ACTIVITIES THAT A PART OF AN
ACADEMIC CAREER AND THAT'S I'M
QUOTING FROM ONE OF OUR WEBSITES
THAT.
EXPLAINS IT A BIT MORE DETAIL
ABOUT WHAT WE EXPECT TO SEE.
AND I THINK THAT WHY THAT'S
IMPORTANT.
BUT THE DIFFERENCE THAT THAT
MAKES IT IS THAT IT ONCE AGAIN
INDICATES OUR COMMITMENT.
SO TO ALL THE PEOPLE ALL THE
APPLICANTS FOR POSITIONS IT
INDICATES OUR COMMITMENT --
I SUSPECT BUT I DON'T HAVE ANY
DATA TO SUPPORT THIS THAT IT
MIGHT DISCOURAGE SOME THAT HAVE
DIFFERENT GOALS.
AND THE NUMBER THREE IT GIVES US
A BASIS TO DETERMINE THE FATE TO
THE MISSION OF UC RIVERSIDE.
SO HOW WE GOING TO TELL WHETHER
SOMEONE IS --
COMMITTED TO OUR MISSION.
THE FULL THING WE DID DOES THAT
WE REQUIRE FULL SEARCH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO TAKE BOTH AN ONLINE
COURSE GOVERNING THE
EXPECTATIONS AND LEGALITIES OF
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
IN AN ERA WITH PROPOSITION.
TWO OH NINE AND ALSO AN IN
PERSON INTERACTIVE ONE AND A
HALF HOUR WORKSHOP.
WHERE WE FOCUSED FIRST ON THE
PHILOSOPHY BEHIND THE INITIATIVE
WHAT ARE WE DOING THIS WHAT ARE
WE TRYING TO ACHIEVE WHAT WE?
WHAT IT WHAT WE THINK IT'S GOING
TO DO FOR OUR STUDENTS AND FAR
OFF FACULTY --
WE ALSO FOCUS ON HOW TO
RECOGNIZE AND OVERCOME IMPLICIT
BIAS SEES.
AND WE ALSO FOCUS ON HOW TO
EVALUATE THESE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
DIVERSE CITY STATEMENTS SO WHAT
WE DO IS GO THROUGH SOME
EXAMPLES OF SUCH STATEMENTS AND
WE TALK ABOUT WHAT'S GOOD ABOUT
THEM AND THEN WALKED COULD BE
IMPROVED ABOUT THEM SO THAT
PEOPLE HAVE.
SOME IDEA HOW TO EVALUATE THEM
BECAUSE THIS IS A NEW ASPECT OF
AN APPLICATION.
AND WE FOUND TO THAT PRIOR TO
THIS TIME OFF FACULTY WERE
FLOUNDERING A LITTLE ABOUT
REALLY WHAT DO I DO WITH IT BUT
IT WAS THERE BUT WHAT DO I DO
WITH IT.
AT THE WORKSHOPS WE ALSO
EMPHASIZE THE TREMENDOUS TALENT
POOL FOUND WITHIN THE
CHANCELLOR'S AND PRESIDENT'S
POST DOCTORAL.
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAMS YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT EARLIER --
BUT ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS --
AND USUALLY IT COMES OUT FROM
THE DISCUSSIONS OF IMPLICIT BIAS
SEASON ALSO THE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
DIVERSE CITY STATEMENTS.
IS THAT WE HAVE PO'S TALKING TO
PAY IS IN THE ROOM.
IT IT DOESN'T WORK FOR SOMEONE
TO STAND AT THE FRONT OF THE
ROOM AND JUST SPELL OUT.
WE REALLY ONCE.
THE FACULTY TO BE TALKING TO ONE
ANOTHER ABOUT VARIOUS ISSUES.
AND EXACTLY HOW THESE SESSIONS
GO VARIES TREMENDOUSLY SOMETIMES.
THEY'RE THEY'RE JUST WONDERFUL
YOU THINK WOW I'M SO GLAD TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH ALL THESE
FACULTY AND THEY EVEN APPLAUD AT
THE END AND SOMETIMES.
SHALL WE SAY WE GO OUT OF THERE
FEELING AS IF WE'VE BEEN --
ATTACKED FOR AN HOUR AND A HALF.
BUT EVEN IN THE ONES THAT DON'T
WORK SO WELL AND IT IN SOME WAYS
IN THE ONES THAT DON'T WORK SO
WELL.
DON'T KNOW NOT THEY DON'T WORK
SO WELL DON'T COME OUT FEELING
QUITE SO CONFIDENT THAT WITH
MAKING PROGRESS --
I THINK WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS
BECAUSE WE'VE STOOD UP THOUGHTS
AND FACULTY OF HEARD FROM EACH
OTHER ABOUT THEIR VARIOUS
EXPERIENCES.
AND EVEN THE FACULTY WHO.
OF HAVE FULL BY INTO THE MISSION.
BEFORE THEY GO INTO THESE
WORKSHOPS BECAUSE THAT
COMPULSORY --
THEY THEY STILL COME OUT RE
ENERGIZE BECAUSE THEY REALIZE
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF WORK TO DO
BECAUSE OF THE THINGS THEY'VE
HEARD FROM THEIR FELLOW FACULTY
SO.
AND BECAUSE THESE A COMPULSORY
AND WE'VE HAD THREE YEARS WE'VE
NOW HAD 40% OR MORE THAN 40% OF
THE ENTIRE LADDER RANK FACULTY
GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
AND HAVE TO SIT THERE AND LISTEN.
TO SOME OF US OF IN THIS PROCESS
SO WE'RE MAKING AN IMPACT ON A
VERY LARGE PROPORTION AND AS THE
YEARS GO BY. ONE PRESUMES THAT
THAT PERCENTAGE WILL GO UP.
THE FIFTH THING WE DID IS --
THAT WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED ONE OF
THE ADVANCING FACULTY DIVERSE
CITY.
GRANTS THAT --
SUSAN AND PROGRAMS BROWN --
SORRY VICE PROVOST COLSON
IMPROVISE BROWN WERE TALKING
ABOUT EARLIER.
AND THIS WAS A PROGRAM IN
ENGINEERING.
AND ONE OF THE UNUSUAL POTS OF
THAT PROGRAM WAS THAT WHEN THE
APPLICATIONS K. MEN.
THE THE A SEARCH COMMITTEE COULD
ONLY INITIALLY SEE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO DIVERSE CITY
STATEMENT AND THE RESEARCH
STATEMENT SO THE RESEARCH
STATEMENT TALKS ABOUT WHAT
RESEARCH THE CANDIDATE HAD DONE.
AND PROPOSES TO DO IN THE FUTURE.
SO THOSE WITH THE TWO ELEMENTS
THAT THEIR SEARCH COMMITTEE
COULD SEE FIRST AND ONLY IF BOTH
OF THOSE WERE REALLY GOOD.
DID THE CANDIDATE ADVANCE TO THE
NEXT STAGE OF REVIEW WHEN THEY
STARTED TO LOOK AT YOU KNOW WHAT
OF PUBLISHED WHERE DID THEY
PUBLISH.
AND SO FORTH.
AND I THINK THE THE THE DATE AT
THAT ACTUALLY SHOW THAT THIS
MADE DIFFERENCE.
IS THAT IN THE THE FINAL GRAAF
HERE AND THERE ARE DIFFERENT
COLORS USED FROM THE PREVIOUS
GRAPH -- BUT
IF YOU LOOK AT THE LEFT HAND
SIDE THE A PANEL.
IT GIVES YOU THE DISTRIBUTION OF
CANDIDATES THAT MAKE IT TO THE
SHORT LIST.
NORMALLY IN HIRING DURING THE
HIRING PROCESS IN ENGINEERING
WHERE. 85% A MALE 99% UNKNOWN
YOU ARE RAN.
UP OBVIOUSLY THAN 15% OF FEMALE
AND 1% -- U.
R. M. -- AND
THEN YOU LOOK AT THE THE SHORT
LIST THAT CAME OUT ALL OF THIS
PROGRAM WHERE INSTEAD.
THERE WAS THIS UP FRONT ANALYSIS
OF THE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
DIVERSITY STATEMENT TOGETHER
WITH THE RESEARCH STATEMENT.
ON THE SHORT LIST WAS A 100%
FEMALE --
AND 50% UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITY AND 50% NON UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITY AND FROM
THAT GROUP.
THE FACULTY WHO WERE HIRED --
THERE WERE THREE FACULTY MEMBERS
TWO OF WHOM IDENTIFIED AS UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITIES AND ALL
THREE WERE FEMALE AND IN
ENGINEERING OF BEING FEMALE
MANGER ON UNDER REPRESENTED.
MINORITY [inaudible]
SO.
WE HAD DATA TO SHOW SOMETHING
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
APPROACH SO. THREE FACULTY.
IN TERMS OF NUMBERS IS NOT
CONTRIBUTING VERY MUCH TO WHAT
WE SAW HERE SO THAT THE OTHER
EFFORTS ARE REALLY IMPORTANT.
FOR WHAT THIS --
ACTUAL EXPERIMENT THAT WAS DONE
IN THE MAN OFTEN EXPERIMENT
ALLOWED US TO DO WAS TO ACTUALLY
THEN SHOW THE FACULTY AT THESE
WORKSHOPS WHAT A DIFFERENCE IT
CAN MAKE.
AB AND I DID ALSO.
IN THIS PROCESS BY LAW BY.
DOING THE ANALYSIS ALL OF THE
APPLICATIONS DIFFERENTLY WE
MANAGED TO GET FACULTY FURTHER
AWAY FROM.
USING WHAT WE WOULD CALL A PROXY
MET THE PROXY MEASURES ALL OF
QUALITY.
AND ACADEMIC PEDIGREE.
SO THERE IS A TENDENCY AND YOU
YOU SORT OF ALLUDED TO THIS IDEA
THAT OR SOMEONE DID THAT THAT.
IF.
YOU YOU LIKE FACULTY WHO LOOK
LIKE YOU THINK LIKE YOU AND I
GOING TO DO THE SAME KIND OF
THINGS AS YOU.
BECAUSE YOU FEEL SECURE IN THAT
USE FEEL SECURE IN YOUR
EVALUATION --
BY LOOK BY ANALYZING JUST THE
RESEARCH STATEMENT.
RATHER THAN WHERE THEY DID THEIR
DEGREE --
AND BY ANALYZING THEIR
COMMITMENT TO DIVERSITY YOU YOU
TOOK ON BOARD PEOPLE WHO WERE
EXCELLENT IN RESEARCH BUT ALSO
HAD A TRUE COMMITMENT TO THE
MISSION OF THE UNIVERSITY AND IT
CLEARLY HAS MADE A DIFFERENCE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PLEASE.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN DATED MEMBERS
OF THE HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE --
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
OUR LOCAL ACTIVITIES AT UC
IRVINE TO ADVANCE FINALLY
DIVERSITY --
OF COURSE MY NAME IS DOUGLAS
HAYNES EMMA ACADEMIC
ADMINISTRATOR BUT I'M ALSO A
FACULTY MEMBER.
I'VE BEEN AT UCI FOR TWENTY SIX
YEARS AS A MODERN EUROPEAN
HISTORIAN.
I'M A FORMER UC PRESENCE
POSTDOCTORAL FELLOW.
I'M THE YOUNGEST OF NINE IN A
NATIVE OF CALIFORNIA BORN IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
IS SO THIS IN SOME SENSES COMING
FULL CIRCLE THIS HEARING.
ABOUT WHAT I WANT TO FOCUS ON OF
OUR COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM TO
ADVANCE BADLY DIVERSITY AT UC
IRVINE.
I'M GONNA TALK FIRST --
ABOUT THE OVERALL CURRENT
STRATEGY.
THEN I'M GOING TO FOCUS ON THE
TARGET RECRUITMENT EFFORT --
THROUGH THE RESOURCES OF THE
LEGISLATURE WE'RE ABLE TO PURSUE
LAST YEAR ENTITLED BUILDING OUR
OWN PIPELINE. TO THE STEM
PROFESSORIAL.
THEN I'LL FOCUS ON THE PRECISE
CONCIERGE RECRUITMENT STRATEGY
THAT WE USE. TO YIELD ON
PRESIDENT A NUMBER OF UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITIES AS WELL
AS WOMEN --
IN OUR FOR THREE STEM SCHOOLS
AND FINALLY I WANT TO FOCUS ON
RETENTION.
AND AS MENTIONED EARLIER BY
PROVOST --
BROWN AND OTHERS IT'S IS A MUCH
ABOUT RETENTION AS A RECRUITMENT
WHEN IT COMES TO UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITIES AND WOMEN.
IN ALL ASPECTS OF THE HIGHER
EDUCATION ENTERPRISE.
YOU SEE I AS A HISPANIC SERVING
INSTITUTION AS WELL AS AN ASIAN
AMERICAN NATIVE AMERICAN PACIFIC
ARE OTHER INSTITUTION.
WE ARE RARE INSTITUTION AMONG
THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITIES TO HAVE THAT DUAL
DESIGNATION IT'S ALSO SHARED BY
UC SANTA BARBARA.
AND RECENTLY UC DAVIS WILL BE A
H. S. I CAMPUS AS WELL.
AS A MINORITY SERVING
INSTITUTIONS INCLUSIVE
EXCELLENCE ANIMATES UCI'S
COMPREHENSIVE FACULTY
RECRUITMENT STRATEGY.
THE STRATEGY CONSIST OF HIRING
TO NATIONAL AVAILABILITY.
ENGAGING THE BROADEST CROSS
SECTION OF TALENTED RESEARCHERS
AND SCHOLARS.
AND IF USING ACCOUNTABILITY WITH
ACT A KEY MILESTONE TO THE
SEARCH PROCESS.
THIS STRATEGY IS FORTIFIED IN
THREE KEY WASTE.
ALL APPLICANTS FOR FAMILY
POSITIONS ARE REQUIRED TO SUBMIT
A STATEMENT MY CONTRIBUTION TO
DIVERSITY.
DEAN'S ARE DIRECTED TO OUT REACH
TO THEIR NATIONAL PEERS DRYING
PARTICULAR ATTENTION TO THE
CAMPUS COMMITMENT TO INCLUSIVE
EXCELLENCE.
AND SCHOOL BASS EQUITY ADVISES
PROVIDE OPERATIONAL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THEY SHARE BEST PRACTICES WITH
COMMITTEES WHILE MONITORING
SEARCH SEARCH IS A KEY
MILESTONES.
THEY HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO PAUSE
IN THE SEARCH IN WHICH THERE IS
AN UNEXPLAINED DIVERGENCE
BETWEEN FIELD NATIONAL
AVAILABILITY.
AND THE CHARACTERISTICS OF THE
APPLICANT POOL AND PROPOSE
SHORTLISTS. ONE OF THE EARLY --
ITEMS TO DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO
IS IT ORG CHART OF MY OFFICE.
ON THE LEFT YOU'LL SEE A BOX
THAT LIST THE SEVENTEEN EQUITY
ADVISORS.
THERE'S ONE IN EACH OF THE
ACADEMIC SCHOOLS THAT AS I
DESCRIBED THEY PROVIDE THE
OPERATIONAL ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
EACH REGULAR FACTLY SEARCH.
I WANT MOVED UP --
PART TWO WHICH IS GOING TO FOCUS
ON OUR BUILDING OUR OWN PIPELINE
TO THE STEM PROFESSORIAL.
THAT I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
SUPPORT FROM THE STATE
LEGISLATURE IT'S PLAYED A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE.
IN THIS INITIATIVE.
LAST FALL PENSION AND DISHES
FACTORY HIRING PROGRAM --
WE'RE AND WE SOUGHT TO HIRE
EIGHT FORMER YOU SEE PRESIDENT'S
OR YOU SEE AYE CHANCES
POSTDOCTORAL FELLOWS.
INTO OUR STEM --
SCHOOLS WE SUCCEEDED IN HIRING.
EIGHT ACROSS THREE ACADEMIC
SCHOOLS.
THEY ARE DISTRIBUTED IN THE
FOLLOWING WAY FIVE IN THE
BIOLOGICAL SCIENCES TO AN
INFORMATION COMPUTER SCIENCE AND
ONE IN ENGINEERING.
THESE HIGHLY PROMISING EARLY
CAREER SCIENTISTS NOT ONLY WILL
ADD TO THE RESEARCH AND TEACHING
COMPASSION THE CAMPUS.
BUT ALSO WILL HELP US DIVERSIFY
THE FACULTY INCONSEQUENTIAL WAYS.
AND I NEED TO UNDERSCORE THE
SEVERITY OF UNDER REPRESENTATION
IS PARTICULARLY --
PATENT IN OUR STEM SCHOOLS SO
FIVE OF THE EIGHT NEW FACULTY
ARE WOMEN. THREE IN BIOLOGICAL
SCIENCES TO AN INFORMATION
COMPUTER SCIENCE IN ONE AN
ENGINEERING. FIVE OF THE EIGHT
ARE FROM UNDERREPRESENTED RACIAL
GROUPS THREE AFRICAN AMERICANS
AND TO HISPANIC OR LATIN NECKS.
TO OF THE EIGHT ARE WOMEN OF
COLOR AND I NEED TO UNDERSCORE
THIS THIS SEGMENT OF THE
ACADEMIC WORKFORCE IS EXTREMELY
UNDERREPRESENTED IN STEM
FAMILIES ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES.
NOT JUST DID YOU SEE.
THE IMPACT OF THE PILOT PROGRAM
ALSO CONTRIBUTED TO DRAMATIC
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE DIVERSITY OF
REGULAR HIRES.
ITEM --
YOU'LL SEE THE FIGURE.
THAT.
HIRES ACCOUNTED FOR LAST YEAR
FOR RENTS.
THERE WAS A SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT IN THE HIRING OF
UNDER REPRESENTED MINORITIES IN
OUR STEM SCHOOLS IN COMPARISON
TO THE PREVIOUS TWO YEARS IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THESE NEW HIRES PUSH
THE OVERALL PERCENTAGE OF FORMER
FELLOWS.
ON THE CAMPUS FACULTY 23%.
AND I HAVE A LIST OF FORMER
FELLOWS WHO CURRENTLY ON THE
FAMILY YOU SEE I THAT'S THE ITEM.
THREE I WOULD MOVE --
TO THE THIRD PARTY BY
PRESENTATION WHICH FOCUSES ON
THE RECRUITMENT STRATEGY THAT WE
DEPLOYED IN BUILDING OUR OWN
PIPELINE TO THE STAMP
PROFESSORIAL.
THE ADVANCING FINALLY DIVERSITY
GRAD ENABLE THE CAMPUS TO
COMBINE EXISTING PROGRAMS INTO A
COHERENT TWO PART STRATEGY.
THIS STRATEGY INCENTIVIZE THE
HIRING OF FORMER FELLOWS AN
INVESTOR DIRECTLY IN THEIR
FUTURE CAREER SUCCESSES FACULTY.
AS EXPLICIT PART OF THE
RECRUITMENT PROCESS.
THE PROVOST MAXIMIZE UTILIZATION
OF THE UC PRESENTS HIGHER
INCENTIVE BY MATCHING EACH
INSTEAD OF HIGHER.
WITH FOUR FULLY FUNDED F. T.
E.'S FOR TOTAL OF EIGHT
POTENTIAL HIRES.
SCHOOLS IN TURN.
ADOPTED A CONCIERGE RECRUITMENT
STRATEGY WHERE AN EACH SCHOOL
DEAN PASTOR EQUITY ADVISER. TO
SERVE AS A TRUSTED RESOURCE
ABOUT THE RECRUITMENT PROCESS.
CAMPUS WORK LIFE BALANCE TOOLS
AND OTHER RESOURCES.
THE CAMPUS UNDERSCORE ITS
COMMITMENT TO THE CARE SUCCESS
OF THESE FELLOWS AS FACULTY IN
THE FOLLOWING WAYS.
EACH NEW FACULTY MEMBER RECEIVED
A SIXTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION TO THEIR STARTER
BUDGET.
AND A GRANT FOR THE TUITION TO
PARTICIPATE.
IN THE FACULTY SUCCESS PROGRAM.
A FEATURED GRAHAM OF THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR FACULTY
DEVELOPMENT DIVERSITY.
FINALLY THE CAMPUS STEPS TO
SOCIETY OF INCLUSIVE ACTIONS
FELLOWS TO CREATE A VINEYARD FOR
CAREER DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY
AMONG NEW AND FORMER FELONS.
FINALLY I WANT TO TURN TO THE
FOURTH PART AND THAT IS
RETAINING AND ADVANCING FACULTY.
AND AGAIN THE BUILDING OUR
PIPELINE TO THE STEM
PROFESSORIAL DEMONSTRATED THAT
IT IS POSSIBLE TO DIVERSIFY THE
FACULTY.
RAPIDLY.
BUT IS NOT ENOUGH TO HIRE
DIVERSE FACULTY.
IT IS ESSENTIAL TO SUPPORT THEIR
TRANSMIT.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN YOU SEE I RECEIVED A
SECOND ADVANCING FINALLY
DIVERSITY GRANT. TO PILOT A KERR
CAREER CONCIERGE APPROACH TO
INCREASE FACULTY RETENTION AMONG
THE STEM SCHOOLS.
IT ORGANIZES CAREER ADVISING OR
MENTORING FOR NEW FACULTY BASED
ON A TEAM OF SENIOR COLLEAGUES
RATHER THAN A SINGLE INDIVIDUAL.
THE TEAM COLLABORATES TO SUPPORT
THE RESEARCH TEACHING AND
SERVICE PRIORITIES THE JUNIOR
FACULTY MEMBER WHILE PREPARING
THEM FOR THE CRITICAL THIRD YEAR
APPRAISAL.
THEY WILL PROVIDE INSTITUTIONAL
KNOWLEDGE INNOVATIVE TEACHING
AND RESEARCH PRACTICES PATHWAYS
TO TENURE AT PROFESSIONAL
EXPERTISE.
THESE CAREER TEAMS WILL BE
COMPLEMENTED BY MONTHLY
WORKSHOPS AND FUNDING FOR CAREER
TRAVEL AWARDS TO SUPPORT MENTOR
AND JUNIOR FACULTY PARTICIPATION.
AND CAREER BUILDING PROFESSIONAL --
MEETINGS OUT WE HAVE A LOGIC
MODEL THAT WE PROVIDE IT AT THE
END OF OUR PACKET THAT DESCRIBES --
THE INPUTS AND THE OUTCOMES THAT
WE EXPECT FROM UTILIZING THIS
GRANT --
FROM THE ADVANCING FOUND THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
CHAIRED AMOUNTS AND THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY.
SO I KNOW I'M YOUNGER THAN YOU --
BUT ACTUALLY IT'S BEEN OVER
TWENTY YEARS SINCE I I WAS A LAW
STUDENT AT HARVARD LAW SCHOOL.
AND THE CO CHAIR OF THE VALLEY
AND SARAH.
IN FOUR YEARS LANCE I HAD BEEN
ADVOCATING.
FOR THE HIGHER OF AT LEAST ONE
IN THE HISTORY OF THE LAW SCHOOL
SINCE ITS FOUNDING.
IN EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN WHO WAS
LATIN ACTS.
THEN I WENT BACK TWENTY YEARS
LATER FOR MY REUNION IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND THE LAW SCHOOL HAD
ONLY HIGHER.
TO FACULTY WHO IDENTIFIED AS
LATINO.
AND AS THE ALUMNI MET WITH THE
YOUNG GENERATION OF LIONS OF
STUDENTS --
IT WAS CLEAR THAT THEY STILL
FELT LONELY.
AND ISOLATED IN THE EXPERIENCE --
I GUESS I CAN SHARE THE STORY
FOR TWO REASONS --
ONE IS TO THANK YOU BECAUSE WHAT
A DIFFERENCE IT WOULD HAVE MADE
IF.
THE MASSACHUSETTS LEGISLATURE
HAD JURISDICTION TO TELL HARD
ROAD WHAT TO DO --
BUT ALSO IF THEY HAD
DEMONSTRATED THE COMMITMENT THAT
YOU ARE DEMONSTRATING.
TODAY I THINK THAT MANY OF US
WHO FELT SO LONELY IN OUR ASK.
WOULD HAVE FELT REALLY EMPOWERED
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU BECAUSE
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT --
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT --
WE ARE DOING BETTER THAN HARVARD
LAW SCHOOL EVEN AS THEY DO HAVE
MORE RESOURCES --
I JOINED UC DAVIS A YEAR AND A
HALF AGO ROUGHLY AND WHEREAS I
SHARE YOUR FRUSTRATION AND
URGENCY WITH.
OUR WHAT WE SEE IS A LACK OF
PROGRESS IN.
OUR DIVERT THE FACULTY RANKS --
IT'S NOT FOR LACK OF TRYING AND
I DO WANT TO TELL YOU A FEW OF
THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE BEEN.
DOING -- BUT
IN MY REMARKS I DO WANT REFER.
TO AND THERE WAS A BLUE FOLDER
AND THERE'S A HAND OUT --
AND I WANT TO START WITH THE
SECOND PAGE --
THERE IS A GRAPH THAT MY
ANALYSTS PUT TOGETHER THAT I
THINK IT'S A VERY TELLING CRAFT
AND MAY PROVIDE.
SOME OF THE REASONS WHY WE
STRUGGLE SO MUCH TO DIVERSIFY
THE FACULTY ONE SO WHAT THIS
DOES IS IT KIND OF GIVES US A
PICTURE OF THE FACULTY AT UC
DAVIS IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN BY THE
DATE OF HIRE.
AND WHAT YOU SEE IS THAT.
THE FACULTY AT UC DAVIS IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AT LEAST ONE OF
THEM.
DATES BACK ALL THE WAY TO
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX THAT'S WHEN
THEY WERE HIRED.
THAT MEANS THAT.
OVER FIFTY YEARS AGO SO WHAT WE
KNOW RIGHT IS THAT ONCE HIRED
FACULTY STAY IN GENERAL FOR A
REALLY REALLY LONG TIME AT
INSTITUTIONS.
BUT THE OTHER IMPORTANT PICTURE
OF THIS GRAPH RIGHT IS THAT WHAT
YOU SEE IS THAT WE HAVE A LEGACY
OF WHITENESS RIDE IS THAT WE
DIDN'T ACTUALLY START TO HIRE.
WITH DIVERSE CITY UNTIL THE MORE
RECENT YEARS AND QUITE FRANKLY
FROM AT LEAST FROM WHERE I SIT.
WE CAN ONLY REALLY HIGHLIGHT --
ANY REAL MOVEMENT IN THE LAST
SEVEN YEARS OR SO --
FOR TWO REASONS ONE IS BECAUSE
WE ARE.
A HIRING WITH GREATER DIVERSITY.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST A CERTAIN TYPE
OF DIVERSITY IN PREVIOUS YEARS
YOU KNOW DIVERSITY WAS NOT THAT
IT'S NOT AND IT'S NOT A A DIG
AGAINST IF WE DIDN'T SEE A LOT
OF RANGE IN THE TYPES OF
DIVERSITY THAT WENT BUT THAT WAS
BEING.
HIRED AT UC DAVIS UNTIL THE LAST
SEVEN YEARS OR SO.
SO I THINK THAT'S THE TELEGRAPH.
AND I THINK PART OF THE QUESTION
THEN BECOMES WHAT'S DIFFERENT
YOU KNOW WHAT IS.
HAPPENING IN THE LAST SEVEN
YEARS OR SO THAT'S MAKING.
A DIFFERENCE I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT --
I GUESS.
TO A PIGGY BACK OFF OF VICE
PROVOST FOR AB PROPOSED BROWN'S
ENTHUSIASM.
I'M I DO THINK THAT.
THIS IMAGE OF DIVERSITY CREATE
THE CRITICAL MASS AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT ONCE YOU HAVE A
CRITICAL MASS.
I WOULD LIKE TO BELIEVE THAT YOU
SEE A REPLICATION OF THE SAME
SIMILAR TYPES OF INTERVENTIONS
THAT I HOPE WILL WILL AT SPEED
UP SOME OF THE EFFORTS THAT WE
ARE UNDERTAKING AT LEAST THAT'S
MY HOPE --
BUT IN TERMS OF WHAT IS
DIFFERENT THE TYPES OF
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE HAVE BEEN.
DOING -- ON
THE NEXT PAGE --
WE TRY TO SHOW YOU --
THROUGH THESE VERY AS BLUE
CIRCLES WHAT THE HIRING PROCESS
LOOKS LIKE AT UC DAVIS FROM
RECRUITMENT ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
HIGHER AND ON THE SIDE WE'VE
IDENTIFIED SOME OF THE
INTERVENTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
IN PLACE PARTICULARLY IN RECENT
YEARS IN ORDER TO IMPROVE --
THE WAY THAT WE HIGHER WITH.
DIVERSITY.
I'M GONNA HIGHLIGHT JUST A FEW
OF THOSE INTERVENTIONS.
BUT I DO WANT TO SAY.
THAT.
IN MY MIND THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
SUCCESS THAT I THINK ARE
CRITICAL TO HIGHLIGHT.
I'M FIRST IS THAT MOST OF THESE
INNOVATIONS HAVE BEEN DESIGNED
BY COMMITTED AND ENGAGE FACULTY.
AND WITH SUPPORT OF THE ACADEMIC
SENATE -- I
HAPPEN TO JOIN UC DAVIS --
RECENTLY AFTER WE RECEIVED A
GRANT FROM ADVANCE THE NATIONAL
SCIENCE FOUNDATION IN.
TWENTY TWELVE AND THE OTHER
SOUTH SAID.
FIRST OF ALL IT WAS A BUNCH OF
WOMEN SCIENTIST.
WHO SAW AROUND TODAY SAID WE
CAN'T CONTINUE TO DO THINGS LIKE
THIS WE HAVE TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE?
AND THEY WANT TO THE AND THE
STAFF AND THEY TRIED A COUPLE OF
TIMES THE FIRST TIME IN
SUCCESSFULLY THE SECOND TIME.
BECAUSE THE NSF SAID YOU GOTTA
FOCUS ON STEM AT THE
INTERSECTION OF RACE AND GENDER --
AND IT WAS REALLY THIS
COLLECTIVE EFFORT OF THE FACULTY
WITH A LOT OF SUPPORT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION LEADERSHIP.
THAT RESULTED IN.
THE HIGHER OF NARAL THIRTY
FACULTY MEMBERS WHO ARE BRINGING
MULTICULTURAL PERSPECTIVE SINCE
DAM -- TO UC
DAVIS AND AND I BELIEVE IN THAT
MODEL SO ONE OF THE FIRST
PRESCRIPTIONS.
IS THE COMMITMENT OF FACULTY
SUPPORT OF THE ACADEMIC SENATE
BUT OBVIOUSLY CLOSE
COLLABORATION WITH A
ADMINISTRATIVE LEADERSHIP.
I'M THE SECOND THING I WANT TO
SAY IS THAT NO MATTER HOW MUCH
WE WOULD LIKE TO BELIEVE THAT.
PEOPLE WILL DO THIS JUST BECAUSE
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO WHAT
I HAVE LEARNED IS THAT YOU KINDA
NEED CARROTS IT'S THE REALITY
CHANGING CULTURE IS REALLY
DIFFICULT TO DO.
AND UNFORTUNATELY SOMETIMES THAT
REQUIRES INTENSE INCENTIVIZING
PEOPLE TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT THE CARE
VERSUS HAVE MATTERED --
IN I DO WANT TO SAY THAT THAT
OUR PARTNERS IN THAT REGARD ARE
IMPORTANT INCLUDING YOUR
PARTNERSHIP UC DAVIS HAS
RECEIVED. TWO GRANTS TOTALING
MORE THAN THEM MILLION DOLLARS
THAT HAS ALLOWED US TO INNOVATE
SO WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT --
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT UC DAVIS
HAS ALSO INVESTED SUBSTANTIALLY
TO AND INCENTIVIZE HIRING.
WITH DIVERSE AND I WANT TO CALL
YOUR ATTENTION.
TO THIS THAT THE NEXT PAGE AND
THAT SHOWS --
AT THE VERY BOTTOM YOU SEE THESE
LITTLE FIGURES.
THAT INCLUDES THE THIRTY HIGHER
IS THAT WE HAVE DONE WITH MULTI
CULTURAL PERSPECTIVES ALL OF
THEM CAME AS A RESULT OF
INCENTIVES AND THE INCENTIVES.
ARE IN THE AMOUNT OF EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR
FIVE YEARS TO INCENTIVIZE THESE
HIRES AND THAT'S GOING TO BE A A
STEADY COMMITMENT ON THE PART OF
UC DAVIS IS AN OVER. THREE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT TO DO
WHAT'S THIRTY HIGHER OF THIRTY
FIVE FACULTY --
AND THEN AS THEY READ AS THE
CYCLE OUT OF THE FIVE YEARS OF
INCENTIVIZE MONIES WE HIRE MORE
SO WE'RE HOPING THAT THAT THIS
MODEL WHICH HAS PROVEN
SUCCESSFUL SO FAR WILL CONTINUE
TO HELP US.
TO INCREASE THE NUMBERS.
I WANT TO SAY THAT PROCESS
MATTERS A LOT AND ONE OF THE
THINGS AND CHAIRMAN MEDINA THAT
YOU MENTIONED WAS.
THE TENDENCY --
WANTING TO REPLICATE YOURSELF --
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'M
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT --
IS THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE MANY
WAYS INCENTIVIZING THROUGH THE
NEW GRANT THAT WERE RECEIVED
FROM THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
BUT ALSO --
USING A BIT OF A STICK MODEL TO
FOREST'S NOT FORCE BUT REALLY
REALLY INCENTIVIZE OPEN SEARCHES.
RIGHT RATHER THAN THE
SPECIALIZED NARAL SEARCHES THAT
YOU'VE DESCRIBED --
IN EIGHT COLLEGES AND SCHOOLS --
AND THE DEANS HAVE COMMITTED TO
THAT MODEL --
I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT IT
BECAUSE THEY ALSO COMMITTED. TWO
A MODEL WHERE THEY WILL ALLOW
THE ADMINISTRATIVE LEADERSHIP
INCLUDING MYSELF AND MANY OTHERS.
TO SIT AS PART OF THE HIRING
COMMITTEES AND IN ORDER.
TO TALK ABOUT THE BEST PRACTICES
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN DESCRIBING
AND ENSURING THAT THEY ARE
PRESENT.
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS.
I ALSO WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES I THINK
ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES ARE DOING
THAT.
BUT THE ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES
DO MATTER AND THEY FUNCTION VERY
SIMILARLY.
ACROSS CAMPUSES WHICH IS THAT.
WE DO ASK.
EVERY SINGLE SEARCH TO GIVE US
THEIR NUMBERS IN TERMS OF THE
SHORT LIST THE AND THE ALSO THE
NUMBER OF CANDIDTES.
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BRING BACK
TO CAMPUS TO YOU AND WE COMPARE
THEM AGAINST NORMS --
FOR BASICALLY THE SHORTLIST ARE
REVIEWED TO ENSURE THAT THE
APPLICANT POOL AND SELECTED
CANDIDATES ARE CONSISTENT WITH
THE WORKFORCE AVAILABILITY POOL.
AND WHERE IS THIS IS SORT OF A
SOFT PRESSURE ON THE SEARCH
COMMITTEES I DO FIND THAT TEENS
DON'T WANT TO GET THAT CALL FROM
THE VICE PROVOST TO SAY WHY IS
THERE NO MATCH.
AND I DO THINK IT CREATES A
CULTURE OF KNOWING THAT THE
INSTITUTION CARES ABOUT THIS
ISSUE.
AND IT SLOWLY STARTS TO CHIP
AWAY AT THE NON ACCOUNTABILITY
IN WHICH FACULTY HAVE GENERALLY
HIRED IN THE PAST.
I WANT TO TALK ALSO A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT --
RETENTION.
SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS HAND
OUT OF WE'VE LISTED SOME OF THE
IT RETENTION INITIATIVES AND
BECAUSE OF TIME.
I WON'T TALK ABOUT ALL OF THOSE
INITIATIVES.
BUT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT JUST
TWO ONE IS ONE THAT I HAVE BEEN
LEADING WITH --
A FACULTY DIRECTOR MARY LOU
DELLUMS FEELINGS AND SO THE
FACULTY SCHOLARS THAT WE MENTION
TO YOU THE THIRTY FACULTY
SCHOLARS THEY ARE PART OF A
COHORT OF FACULTY.
THAT WE CALLED CAMPBELL'S AND
CUMPLE STAND A MULTIPLE CULTURAL
PERSPECTIVES ON SCIENCE.
SO WE UNDERSTOOD THAT THEIR
PRESENCE ON CAMPUS WAS GONNA BE
TRANSFORMATIVE BUT WE ALSO
UNDERSTOOD THAT THEY NEEDED TO
BE SUPPORTED AND MADE VISIBLE
AND THAT THERE THAT THEY WE
NEEDED TO BUILD A COMMUNITY
AROUND THEM.
AND I AND I'M HAPPY TO SAY THAT --
WE HAVE DONE THAT QUITE
SUCCESSFULLY AND NOW WE'RE
TRYING TO REPLICATE.
ON A SIMILAR MODEL FOR FOR
FACULTY IN THE SOCIAL SCIENCES
HUMANITIES AND THE ARTS.
I'M LET ME --
FINALLY TALK ABOUT THE PIPELINE
TO THE PROFESSORIAL BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT ALSO
DELAYS THE RATE AT WHICH WE CAN
DIVERSIFY FACULTY.
I PROVIDE --
IN THE HANDOUT THAT WE GAVE YOU --
SOMEONE THE SECOND TO LAST PAGE.
SOME OF THE DATA ON NATIONAL
STATISTICS ON I'M ACTUALLY
THAT'S A VERY LAST PAGE
STATISTICS ON STUDENTS IN
GRADUATE SCHOOL TODAY AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL AT LEAST.
FOR TWENTY FIFTEEN IT'S
DISTRESSING TO SEE THAT ONLY 6%
OF GRADUATE --
DEGREES ARE EARNED BY
INDIVIDUALS WHO IDENTIFIED AS
HISPANIC OR LATIN ACTS AND ONLY
6% OF THOSE WHO IDENTIFY.
AS BLACK OF OR AFRICAN AMERICAN.
LAST WEEK AYE PARTICIPATED IN
THIS INCREDIBLE --
FORUM FUNDED THROUGH THE MAILING
GRANT FOUNDATION ON IT'S A NEW
INITIATIVE THE WE ARE
SPEARHEADING CALLED THE ALLIANCE
FOR MULTI CAMPUS INCLUSIVE
GRADUATE ADMISSIONS OR AMIGA.
THIS GRANT IS GETTING THE ELITE
INSTITUTIONS LIKE UCLA --
UC'S AT UC DAVIS AND USC TO COME
TOGETHER TO TO HAVE A MUCH MORE
HONEST CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
WAY THAT WE ASSESS MERIT.
IN ORDER.
TO ADMIT STUDENTS INTO GRADUATE
SCHOOL.
AND IT WAS A ROOM FULL OF
ACADEMICS HAVING A REALLY HONEST
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
HOW OUR RELIANCE ON THE JURY E.
THE CITY HAS BEEN A RACIALIZED
PROJECT?
THAT HAS CREATED A MERITOCRACY
THAT EXCLUDES PEOPLE AND I HAVE
TO TELL YOU I WAS ASKED TO GIVE
THE KEYNOTE ADDRESS.
AND I WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS ABOUT
IT BECAUSE THEY TEND TO BE
CRITICAL IN THE WAY THAT I SPEAK --
AND I IN MY TITLE A TITLE THAT
THE LESSONS THAT BAKI OFFERS TO
HOLISTIC ADMISSIONS.
MAN I TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THE WAY THAT WE HAVE FRAME THE
LANGUAGE A MERITOCRACY --
MEANS THAT WE PLACE LEE CREATED
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AND AND RACE
BASED ADMISSIONS RATHER THAN
CHALLENGING THE VERY CORE.
WHICH IS ALL OF MERITOCRACY
WHICH IS THAT IT ACTUALLY DOES
THE WORK JERRY'S DOES NOT DO NOT
MEASURE SUCCESS AND THEY'RE NOT
EFFECTIVE AT HELPING US TO
MEASURE SUCCESS.
AND WHAT I WANT TO TELL YOU IS
THAT I WAS SO.
INSPIRED BY A GROUP OF FACULTY
WHO AGREE WITH THAT PREMISE AND
WHO ARE REALLY TRYING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN GRADUATE
ADMISSIONS --
SO THIS IS ALL TO SAY I WE WERE
WE NEED TO BE ABSOLUTELY NOT.
BUT I DO THINK WE'RE TRYING IS
THAT ENOUGH AS A METRIC I'M NOT
SURE BUT I HOPE I HOPE THE
REASON I'M HERE.
AND AT UC DAVIS BECAUSE IT'S NOT
AN EASY JOB IS BECAUSE I'D LIKE
TO BELIEVE THAT WE CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IF WE TRY --
BUT WE NEED YOUR PARTNERSHIP AND
AND AND YOUR PATIENCE ARM AND
YOUR COMMITMENT TO US AND SO I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
BEING THE LAST MEMBER HERE.
I I'M GOING TO SKIP ANY
QUESTIONS OR BECAUSE I WANT TO
MOVE FORWARD AND I CERTAINLY
WANT TO HAVE TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT.
SO I THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
APPRECIATE --
THE THE VIEW FROM THE CAMPUSES
SO THANK.
AND WITH THAT WE'LL GO.
TO OUR FOURTH PANEL.
SO WOULD LIKE TO HEAR AND KNOW
MORE ABOUT.
UNDER REPRESENTED FACULTY.
THE BALANCE IN THEIR CLASSROOM
ROSE AND IN MANY CASES THEIR
DEFAULT ROLES OF BEING MENTORS
TO UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS
WHICH WE'VE.
BEEN HEARING ABOUT THROUGHOUT
THE THE HEARING.
AS A FORMER TEACHER I CANNOT
LEAVE OUT STUDENTS AND AS A
MATTER OF FACT WITHOUT LOOKING
AT THIS.
YOU KNOW THE STUDENTS ARE THE
REASON FOR US BEING HERE --
THE REASON IS IS FOR OUR VERY
BEING.
AND SO I'D LIKE TO WELCOME.
CHAIR OF THE UC AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION DIVERSITY EQUITY
COMMITTEE.
BLOCKS TO P. AND THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
CAROLINE SEGAL'S.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE MEDINA.
I THINK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON ON THE IMPORTANT
ISSUE OF FIVE FACULTY DIVERSITY
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
INCLUDING THE FACULTY
PERSPECTIVE --
IN THIS HEARING.
MY NAME IS LAW SEE YOU AND I AM
A FACULTY MEMBER AT IN THE
ETHNIC STUDIES DEPARTMENT AT UC
BERKELEY.
I WAS ALSO A AN ALUMNI OF THE UC
BERKELEY --
UP CAMPUS AS WELL.
THE ACADEMIC SENATE PLAYS A
CRUCIAL ROLE IN SHARED
GOVERNANCE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE SENATE WORKS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DEVELOP
POLICIES FOR THE BETTERMENT OF
THE UNIVERSITY.
I CHAIR THE SYSTEM Y. ACADEMIC
SENATE UNIVERSITY COMMITTEE ON
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION DIVERSITY AND
EQUITY.
YOU CANNOT FOR SHORT.
THIS COMMITTEE CONSIDERS GENERAL
POLICIES THE CONCERN AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION DIVERSITY AND EQUITY AN
ACADEMIC PERSONNEL AND ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS.
AS A FIRST GENERATION WOMAN OF
COLOR FACULTY AT UC BERKELEY.
I'M INTENSELY AWARE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT MANY WOMEN AND
RACIAL MINORITY STUDENTS AND
FACULTY FACE.
I TEACH IN THE AND THE ETHNIC
STUDIES DEPARTMENT AFTER ALL.
GRADUATE STUDENTS MOSTLY WOMEN
AND RACIAL MINORITIES COME
SEEKING NOT JUST RESEARCH
SUPPORT BUT ALSO PROFESSIONAL
MENTORING --
PROJECTS COVER A VARIETY OF
ISSUES THEY COME FROM A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS AND
SCHOOLS. ONE STUDENT IN AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDIES DID RESEARCH ON
MAROON DESCENDED COMMUNITIES IN
THE U. S. SELF.
ANOTHER COMMUNITY ANOTHER
STUDENT IN SPANISH AND
PORTUGUESE TO STUDYING
REPRESENTATIONS OF INDIGENOUS.
PEOPLES AND ASIAN MIGRANTS IN
LATIN AMERICAN LITERATURE.
AND ANOTHER STUDENT ETHNIC
STUDIES IS COMPLETING HER
DISSERTATION ON THE AGING LATINO
POPULATION IN THE UNITED STATES.
I CANNOT ALWAYS CLAIM SPECIFIC
BUT I AM ALWAYS WILLING TO
SUPPORT AND GUIDE THEM.
I LISTEN TO THEIR FRUSTRATIONS
THEIR FEARS OF FAILURE AND THEIR
DREAMS OF MAKING A DIFFERENCE
FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND I MENTOR THEM BY SHERRY
LESSONS I HAVE.
AND ADVICE ON HOW TO NAVIGATE
BOTH THE RESEARCH PROCESS AS
WELL AS THE ACADEMY.
AS A CURRENT MEMBER OF OUT TO
YOU SEE AND AS AN ALUMNA I
UNDERSTAND IN THE MOST PROFOUND
WAY THE NEED TO DIVERSIFY OUR
FACULTY.
AS CHAIR OF YOU CANNOT I WANT TO
SHARE WITH YOU OUR CURRENT
INITIATIVES THAT HELP ADVANCE
FACULTY DIVERSITY.
AS WELL AS THE HIGHLIGHT ONE
PARTICULAR AREA WHERE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IS WELCOME AND NEEDED.
TO DIVERSIFY FACULTY AT UC WE
MUST FIRST CREATE A SOLID
PIPELINE FOR WOMEN AND
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
SCHOLARS TO ENTER INTO LETTERING
POSITIONS.
I THINK YOU'VE HEARD QUITE A BIT
ABOUT THAT AMONG THE EARLIER
PANELS. TO ACHIEVE IN DURING A
MEANINGFUL CHANGE WE NEED TO
TRANSFORM BOTH THE CULTURAL
NORMS AND THE INSTITUTIONAL
PRACTICES.
INITIATIVES THAT YOU CAT IS
UNDERTAKING THIS YEAR AIM TO
ADDRESS BOTH.
FIRST YOU CANNOT IS PROPOSING AN
EXPANSION OF THE PRESIDENT'S
POST DOCTORAL FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE GROWING
NEEDS IN THE HIRING OF THESE
FELLOWS.
AS A SIGNATURE PROGRAM AT THE
YOU SEE SINCE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR THE
PRESIDENT'S POSTDOCTORAL FELLOW
PROGRAM IS A COMPETITIVE PROGRAM
THAT OFFERS TWO YEAR RESEARCH
FELLOWSHIPS CAREER DEVELOPMENT
AND FACULTY MENTORING TO
OUTSTANDING SCHOLARS WHO'S
WORKED CAN AND WILL CONTRIBUTE
TO DIVERSITY.
AND EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AT UC.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR TWO
HUNDRED AND FIVE FOLLOWS HAVE
BEEN HIRED INTO THE UC.
CURRENTLY HIRING TRENDS --
AND RECENT CHANGES IN THE HIRING
INCENTIVE AWARDS PROGRAM
INDICATE THAT THE DEMAND FOR
HIRING THESE FELLOWS WILL
CONTINUE TO GROW.
IN ORDER TO MEET THE GROWING
DEMAND AND HIRING WE ARE
RECOMMENDING AN INCREASE.
IN THE NUMBER A FELLOWSHIPS.
AWARDS THE FELLOWSHIP AWARDS
FROM TWENTY TO FORTY ESSENTIALLY
DOUBLING THE CURRENT NUMBER OF
FELLOWSHIP AWARDS.
DOING SO WILL EXPAND THE POOL OF
AND THEREBY ENSURING A HEALTHY
STREAM OR PIPELINE.
OF DIVERSE FACULTY INTO
LOTTERING POSITIONS THROUGHOUT
THE UC CAMPUSES.
IN ADDITION OUR COMMITTEE IS
ALSO AFFECTING LONG TERM CHANGE
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS TO REQUIRE
SYSTEM WHY ADOPTION.
OF BOTH THE FACULTY EQUITY
ADVISER PROGRAM.
AND THE SUBMISSION OF
CONTRIBUTION TO DIVERSITY
STATEMENTS BY ALL APPLICANTS FOR
FACULTY POSITIONS.
THE FACULTY EQUITY ADVISER
PROGRAM INSURERS THAT DIVERSITY
IN EQUITY ARE CONSIDERED
THROUGHOUT THE HIRING PROCESS
AND BEYOND.
THE USE OF CONTRIBUTION TO
DIVERSITY STATEMENTS INSURERS
THAT ALL FACULTY CANDIDATES AT
THE TIME OF APPLICATION HAVE A
CLEAR PLAN TO CONTRIBUTE TOWARD
DIVERSITY WHETHER IT IS IN
RESEARCH IN SERVICE OR IN
TEACHING.
IN FACT YOU CANNOT HOPES TO SEE
THE ADMINISTRATION INTEGRATE THE
USE OF THE STATEMENTS BEYOND THE
APPLICATION STAGE AND INTO THE
REGULAR FACULTY REVIEW PROCESS.
BY ALTERING INSTITUTIONAL
PRACTICE BOTH INITIATIVES AIM TO
MAKE LONG TERM CHANGE.
FURTHER MORE BY RAISING
CONSCIOUSNESS AND AWARENESS AND
HOLDING EVERY FACULTY
ACCOUNTABLE TO DIVERSE CITY.
THESE INITIATIVES WILL TRANSFORM
CULTURAL NORMS AT UC.
THESE ARE IMPORTANT TOOLS TO
HELP ADVANCE FACT THE DIVERSITY
OUT OUT IN A LONG IN THE LONG
TERM.
FINALLY IF I CAN HIGHLIGHT ONE
ADDITIONAL AREA WE'RE SPECIFIC
INTERVENTIONS CAN YIELD IN
DURING RESULTS.
IT WOULD BE TO ENSURE THE
ADVANCEMENT OF WOMEN AND
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
FACULTY THROUGH THE RANKS AND AT
THE VERY SENIOR LEVELS OF THE
ACADEMY.
TIMELY ADVANCEMENT TO TENURE IS
CRITICAL.
AND SO IS TIMELY ADVANCEMENT TO
FULL PROFESSORSHIP.
IT IS AT THE SENIOR LEVEL A FULL
PROFESSORSHIP THE FACULTY
MEMBERS ARE MOST EFFECTIVE IN
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS.
IT IS ALSO WHEN THEY BECOME
ELIGIBLE AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF ADMINISTRATION IN THE
UNIVERSITY. TO AFFECT LONG TERM
CHANGE THEN WE MUST ADVANCE
WOMEN AND UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITY FACULTY TO THE MOST
SENIOR LEVELS AND TO CULTIVATE
THEM TO BECOME LEADERS
THROUGHOUT.
THE UNIVERSITY.
THE ACADEMIC SENATE IS FULLY
COMMITTED TO FACULTY DIVERSITY.
WORKING TOGETHER WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE MADE
PROGRESS.
BUT THERE IS STILL MUCH MORE
WORK TO BE DONE.
WITH YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT WE
WILL MAKE SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN
FACT WE INSIST ON MAKING
TRANSFORMATIVE CHANGE.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK --
TO WITH YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN DANA FOR
INVITING STANDS TO SPEAK AND FOR
TAKING SO MUCH INTEREST IN THIS
ISSUE MY NAME'S CAROLYN SIEGEL
SAYING I'M A CURRENT THIRD YEAR
AT UC SAN DIEGO.
ARM SETTING POLITICAL SCIENCE
PUBLIC POLICY I AM ALSO JOINED
TODAY BY MY GRADUATE COUNTERPART
RACHEL ROBERSON A CURRENT GRAD
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY STUDYING
EDUCATION POLICY.
I'M HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE MY OWN
EXPERIENCES AS A UC STUDENT WITH
THE ISSUE OF FACULTY DIVERSITY
AND HOW IT HAS DEFINED MY
UNDERGRAD EXPERIENCE.
SO I'LL KEEP IT SHORT I KNOW
IT'S LATE.
AS A JUNIOR AT UC SAN DIEGO
THERE HAS NOT BEEN A SINGLE
COURSE I HAVE TAKEN OR I WAS
TAUGHT BY FACULTY MEMBER WHO
LOOKED LIKE ME.
NOT A SINGLE WOMAN OF COLOR HAS
BEEN THE INSTRUCTOR OF THE
THIRTY OR SO COURSES I'VE TAKEN
MY CAMPUS.
THE UNFORTUNATE THING IS MY
EXPERIENCE IS NOT UNIQUE BY ANY
MEANS AND THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S IS KIND OF NORMAL --
DURING THE SEPTEMBER REGION'S
MEETING IS ACTUALLY REPORTED
THAT UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS MAKE UP
TWENTY EIGHT POINT ON PERCENT
THE UC WALL LETTERING FACULTY.
FROM UNDER REPRESENTED GROUPS
MAKE UP ONLY 10% --
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY IN A PIPELINE
IF NONE OF MY PROFESSORS EVEN
LOOK LIKE ME WHO AM I SUPPOSED
TO GO TO FOR CAREER ADVICE
MENTORSHIP OR RESEARCH
OPPORTUNITIES --
ANOTHER THING I WANT TO HIT ON
IS THAT WHEN YOU DON'T SEE
PEOPLE LIKE YOU THE MESSAGE IS
VERY CLEAR.
YOU'RE NOT BELONG HERE.
I COMMEND THE UNIVERSITY FOR
ATTEMPTING TO REMEDY THIS ISSUE
HOWEVER I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
HOW THEY CONTINUE TO WORK ON
FACULTY ADVERSITY.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES --
I'M CURRENTLY AFTER BEGINNING OF
THE PIPELINE SO I'M HOPING THAT
I WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE IT TO THE
ENDS.
I WILL NOW DEFERRED SURE RACHEL
ROBERSON TO SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE
FROM THE GRADUATE SAN
PERSPECTIVE [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON [inaudible]
LOCAL.
THANK YOU I KNOW OUR NUMBERS
HAVE DWINDLED BUT I APPRECIATE
YOU ALL STICKING AROUND IT TO
HEAR THE REST OF US BE --
I WILL TRY MY BEST TO KEEP THIS
BRIEF AS WELL MY NAME IS RACHEL
ROBERSON I AM A PHD CANDIDATE AT
UC BERKELEY SETTING EDUCATION
POLICY.
WITH A SPECIALIZATION IN HIGHER
EDUCATION --
I WILL NOT BORE YOU ALL WITH A
DESCRIPTION OF MY PENDING
DISSERTATION ON MY WILL SAVE
THAT -- FOR
A LATER DATE --
BUT I'LL LIKE TO START JUST BY
SAYING --
THAT I ALSO IDENTIFIES FIRST
GENERATION --
AND TO ME THAT IT HAS VERY MUCH
NATALIE SHAPED --
MY MY CAREER TRAJECTORY ACTION
FOR THE FIELD MY DROP FOR THE
FIELD BUT ALSO --
MY INTENTION TO AS MY COLLEAGUE
HAS STATED TRANSFORM THE VERY
LANDSCAPE OF EDUCATION THAT WE
OPERATE WITHIN --
IF NOT FOR MYSELF --
CERTAINLY --
FOR OTHER FOLKS AT THE BEGINNING
OF THAT PIPELINE AND FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT I HOPE END UP
BEING FED INTO THAT PIPE AND
EVENTUALLY --
NAMELY MY FUTURE CHILDREN AND
CERTAINLY MY NIECES AND NEPHEWS --
I WILL SAY THAT IN DECIDING
WHERE I WANTED TO RECEIVE MY
GRADUATE TRAINING.
ON MENTOR SHIP WAS OF THE UTMOST
IMPORTANCE FOR ME --
I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF BEING
TRAINED BY WOMEN OF COLOR WHO
ALSO HAPPENED TO BE LEADERS IN
THE FIELD --
AND SETTING THE STAGE FOR WHAT
THE EXPECTATION OF THE ACADEMY
WITHIN A PUBLIC --
WITHIN PUBLIC EDUCATION IS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE --
UNFORTUNATELY MY COLLEAGUES IN
OTHER DEPARTMENTS --
CANNOT SAY THE SAME.
I'VE SEEN FAR TOO OFTEN IN A
VERY SHORT TENURE AT UC BERKELEY --
INDIVIDUALS WHO CAME IN AS
RISING STARS WITHIN THE ACADEMY.
FIZZLE OUT AND LEAVE THE
INSTITUTION SHORT COMING OF
DIVERSE FACULTY MENTOR SHIP --
THE UC IS LOSING AN OPPORTUNITY
TO CONTINUE TO BUILD NOT ONLY --
THE THE STRENGTH OF PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION HERE WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO
THROUGHOUT THE NATION AND
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD --
ALL BORROWED FROM THE MY ALMA
MATER THE UNIVERSITY OF TEXAS AT
AUSTIN -- IN
THEIR THEIR MISSION STATEMENT
WHICH IS WHAT STARTS HERE
CHANGES THE WORLD AND WHILE.
WE CAN TALK A LOT ABOUT.
TEXAS BEING A LITTLE TOO BIG FOR
THEIR BRITCHES --
I THINK.
I THINK IT'S TO OUR BEST
INTEREST --
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO THINK CRITICALLY ABOUT WHAT
THAT THOSE WORDS MEAN I'M AND
HOW THEY INTERSECT WITH THE TRUE
COMMITMENT AND VALUE TO
DIVERSITY --
AND WHILE MY EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN
SHAPED VERY MUCH BY STRONG
MENTOR SHIP FROM WOMEN OF COLOR --
THE FACT THAT I CANNOT SAY THE
SAME FOR MY COLLEAGUES --
IS HIGHLY DISAPPOINTING --
IN VERY MUCH --
IMPACTS WHETHER OR NOT I FEEL
VALUED --
WITH IN THIS STATE AND
SPECIFICALLY WITHIN THIS
INSTITUTION AND WHETHER OR NOT
I'D LIKE TO STAY HERE.
IT DOES NOT STOP --
AT THE GRADUATE LEVEL THOUGH --%
AS MY COLLEAGUES STATED --
NOT HAVING A SINGLE --
AS FACULTY MEMBER OF COLOR HIS --
HER WILLINGNESS TO BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS AND TRULY ENGAGE
THAT ONLY WITH OUR CAMPUS
COMMUNITY BUT ALSO WITHIN THE
LARGER ACADEMY AS WELL --
MY COLLEAGUE JOHN HARPER DOWN AT
USC RECENTLY RELEASED A REPORT --
WHICH UNFORTUNATELY PROVIDE SOME
SCATHING --
FINDINGS AROUND THE LACK OF
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF
BLACK STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY --
BUT NAMELY WITHIN THE UC AND
UNFORTUNATELY SPECIFICALLY AT UC
BERKELEY --
NOT SEEING BLACK STUDENTS IN MY
COURSES THAT I GS I HIGH --
IMPACTS AND SHAPES --
THE NUANCES THAT I SEE WITHIN
THE COMPLEXITIES OF EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY --
AND JUST HOW FREQUENTLY WE ARE
FALLING SHORT THROUGH OUT THE
PIPELINE.
WHILE --
PIPELINE FUELING STRUCTURES SUCH
AS THE UC PRESIDENTIAL POSTDOC
THE H. B. C. U. INITIATIVE
SERVICE WONDERFUL FIRST STEPS --
WE DEFINITELY NEED MORE.
AN UNAPOLOGETIC COMMITMENT TO
INVESTING IN FACULTY DIVERSITY
CANNOT AND CONTINUE TO TARGET
BUILDING AN ACADEMIC PIPELINE
BUT CONTINUE ALL THE WAY UP --
THROUGH TENURED A FULL IN
LEADERSHIP ROLES.
ONLY THEN CAN WE PROVIDE A
HOLISTIC WELL RESOURCE APPROACH
THAT CAN ENABLE US AS A
COLLECTIVE CALIFORNIA TO TRULY
LEAD THE WAY.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
WHAT LIKE TO FOLLOW UP JUST A
LITTLE BIT AND QUICKLY --
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
AND YOUR SPECIFICALLY IN HIGHER
EDUCATION.
AT CAL --
HOW MANY DOCTORAL?
STUDENTS IN THE DEPARTMENT ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN.
IF YOU YOU.
MIGHT KNOW.
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION CORRECT OR MAYBE PHD
STUDENTS.
THE OUR GRADUATE SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION IT HAS.
THERE ARE FIFTEEN OF US. FIFTEEN
AFRICAN AMERICAN PHD STUDENTS IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ACCOUNT AND HOW MANY ARE WOMEN.
THERE ARE EIGHT OF US.
AND OF THE FACULTY IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION --
YOU YOU MENTION AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMEN.
DETAIL AT ADDED IT IN HER NUMBER.
YOU MENTIONED THE TICKET THAT
YOU HAD IN THE DEPARTMENT IN
YOUR DEPARTMENT.
OF FACULTY THAT ARE AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN YES MY
DISSERTATION CHAIRS AND AFTER A
MOMENT.
AND ARE THERE OTHERS.
THERE ARE TWO OTHERS --
ONE IS EVERYTHING HIGHER THAT I
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF SITTING ON
HER AND HER HIRING COMMITTEE AND
MIGHT YOU KNOW OF LATINO FACULTY.
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION CAN YOU GIVE ANY IDEA.
HOW MANY I CAN SAY THAT THE THE
NUMBER IS --
SIMILAR OF AS WELL AS WITH IT
THE DEMOGRAPHIC BREAKDOWN OF AND
OF GENDER IDENTITY AS WELL AND
FROM YOUR EXPERIENCE HAVING.
AFRICAN AMERICAN PROFESSORS IN
YOUR DEPARTMENT.
AS A PHD STUDENT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE. 1100% I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THE REASON WHY I LEFT THE
STATE OF TEXAS AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF TEXAS AT THAT WAS
SPECIFICALLY THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH MY ACADEMIC ADVISER --
NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF AGAIN HER
BEING A LEADER IN THE FIELD OF
EDUCATION IN THE CONVERSATIONS
OF EDUCATIONAL EQUITY.
BUT SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE I WANT
THAT BEING TRAINED BY A FELLOW
BLACK WOMAN --
ENTERING INTO A FIELD THAT WAS
NOT ONLY DOMINATED --
BY WHITE MEN BUT AN INSTITUTION
THAT WAS DOMINATED BY WHITE MEN
AND AND WHO'S YOUR FACULTY PHD
ADVISER CHEN ELSE GOT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I I I I WAS ALSO A GRADUATE
STUDENT I WAS A GRADUATE STUDENT
OF HISTORY AT UC RIVERSIDE.
OR GOT MY MASTERS AND AND I
SHARE WITH YOU OF THE DIFFERENCE
THAT HAVING OF FACULTY OF COLOR
MAKES.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE'LL
GO ON AND TO PUBLIC COMMENTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE.
IS.
AND I KNOW I KNOW WE'RE WAY
BEHIND TIME.
BUT BUT I THINK THAT SOMETIMES
THE PUBLIC COMMENT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT.
AND I AND I SEE MANY OF YOU WHO
SAT THROUGH THE WHOLE --
HEARING.
AND I VERY MUCH WANT TO HEAR
FROM THE PUBLIC SO IF YOU WOULD
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
I BELIEVE RIGHT HERE TO THE
RIGHT.
AND I DO WANT TO HEAR FROM
EVERYONE.
UP BUT WE DO HAVE A LIMIT OF TWO
MINUTES --
PER SPEAKER.
OKAY ON YOUR MIND AND I AND I
HAVE MY YOUR TIMER TIMER HERE
OKAY ALL CARRY.
A LOT OF NOTES OKAY I'M I'M NOT
THAT YEAH DEEP SO SIMON
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR TO SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT YOU HEARD IN
THIS HEARING.
SO -- I AM
IN CHICANO CHICANA STUDIES I'M
NOT IN THE STEM FIELDS.
AND WE SERVE THE MAJORITY OF THE
CHICANO CHICANA LATINA LATINO
STUDENTS AT UC DAVIS WE HAVE
FROM THOSE OF FIVE HUNDRED
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AT UC
DAVIS. 70% OF MY STUDENTS ARE
FIRST GENERATION 20% OF THEM ARE
FINANCIALLY IN SECURE 12% OF
THEM ARE HOUSE IN SECURE --
MANY OF THEIR PARENTS ARE OR
MANY OF THEM ARE FROM MAKE
STATUS SO --
ONE OF THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
MIGHT NOT BE DOCUMENTED OR THEM
THOSE ARE.
OR A SOME OF THEIR HOUSES HAVE
BEING REPROCESSED THESE ARE THE
STORIES THAT OUR STUDENTS SHARE
WITH US SO WE HELP THEM NAVIGATE
THROUGH THIS --
OUT WHEN I ARRIVE TO THE
UNIVERSITY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX WHEN I WAS SAID DAVE IS
DOWNTOWN I WAS HOUSE WHERE DO
YOU WORK AND I SAID I UC DAVIS.
AND I WAS ASKED BECAUSE I AM A
LATINA QUITE BUILDING TO WHAT
BUILDING DO THE FIRST ASSUMPTION
WAS THAT A PERSON WHO LOOKED
LIKE ME HOW TO BE A CUSTODIAN --
OR I WAS ASKED BECAUSE I HAVE
DOGS ARE YOU A DOG WALKER.
THIS ARE THE MICRO AGGRESSIONS
THAT A PERSON LIKE ME WHO LOOKS
LIKE ME AND COUNTER SO EVERY DAY
MY STUDENTS ALSO ENCOUNTERED
THEM.
UP POLICE HARASSMENT --
OR WE HAD AT MOROCCO HOLE UP
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN SIGN
POSTED THERE AND THIS IS THE
HOUSE OF THE ETHNIC STUDIES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M GOING TO STOP YOU THERE TWO
MINUTES THANK YOU AND IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF
YES MY NAME IS FRANCISCO NON
THIS I'M A RETIRED VICE
CHANCELLOR FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF OF CALIFORNIA.
MY ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA STARTED
A FIFTY FIFTY YEARS AGO WHEN I
KNOW THAT DURING THAT TIME YOU
SEE HAS BEEN CONTROLLED
CRITICIZED AND SOMETIMES
ATTACKED FOR THE FACT THAT IT
DOES NOT --
HAVE ENOUGH LATINOS AND LATINAS
REPRESENTED AT THE FACULTY AND
ARE ADMINISTRATIVE LEVELS. FOR
THE PAST FIFTY YEARS REPORTS
HAVE BEEN WRITTEN HEARINGS HAVE
BEEN HELD PROBLEMS IS HAVE BEEN
MADE.
AND GOALS HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED
AND THOSE GOALS AND PROMISES
HAVE NOT BEEN MET.
HEY YOU SEE I WAS A STUDENT.
ALARM OF BERKELEY A LECTURE OF
STAFF TO VICE CHANCELLORS AND
CHANCELLORS AND MOST RECENTLY A
A DOT A DONOR.
I WANT TO NOTE THAT WHEN YOU SEE
WANTS TO DO SOMETHING.
IT CAN.
THEY TOOK THREE CAMPUSES THAT
WERE THAT WERE YOUNG AND MADE
THEM INTO A WORLD CLASS
UNIVERSITY SAYS WITNESSED BY
IRVINE SANTA CRUZ AND THE SAN
DIEGO CAMPUS.
IT ALSO TOOK.
I AND CREATED A BRAND NEW CAMPUS
FROM NOTHING AS WITNESSED BY YOU
SEE MERCED.
WHEN YOU SEE WANTS TO ACCOMPLISH
SOMETHING IT CAN ADD DOES AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS WHEN YOU SEE
ESTABLISHES GOALS THAT HE WANTS
TO MEET IT CAN WHEN YOU SEE
WANTS TO ACQUIRE FUNDS WHEN FOR
NEW ENDEAVORS IT DOES?
WHEN YOU SEE WANTS TO IT DOES?
THAT BEGS THE QUESTION WHY SEE
OF CALIFORNIA NOT HAVE THE
REPRESENTATION OF CHICANOS AND
CHECK ON US AMONG ITS FACULTY.
AND IN --
HIGHER ADMINISTRATION.
I BELIEVE THAT THAT LACK OF ROOM
REPRESENTATION IS NOT FROM
MALICE AFORETHOUGHT BUT RATHER
THAT THE SIMPLE FACT THE PUTTING
US IN POSITIONS OF INFLUENCE.
IS JUST NOT IMPORTANT ENOUGH NOT
ENOUGH OF A PRIORITY NOT CRUCIAL
TO THE UNIVERSITY'S
INTERNATIONAL STANDING NOR
DEPENDENT FOR FUTURE GROWTH WHEN
STAFFING PLANS ARE MADE OR
HIRING DECISIONS ARE MADE
INCLUDING US.
IS JUST NOT A MAJOR FACTOR I
KNOW I WAS THERE.
YOU SEE LEADERSHIP.
FACES THE DILEMMA OF HAVING A
STATED GOAL NOT MATCHED BY THE
DESIRE WITHIN ITS RANKS TO
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL.
I ASK WHAT DETRIMENTAL ACTION
HAS BEEN IT HAS BEEN AFFECTED.
OF YOU SEE BECAUSE IT HAS NOT
MET ITS OWN STATED GOALS.
WHAT HAS OCCURRED WITHIN YOU SEE
BECAUSE IT HAS NOT MET ITS OWN
STATED GOALS THE ANSWER IS VERY
LITTLE I KNOW I WAS THERE?
I HAVE THE GREATEST RESPECT FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
THAT I HAVE WITNESSED FROM THE
INSIDE.
I HAVE WATCHED YOU SEE FOR MANY
YEARS EXCEED EXPECTATIONS AND
MEET IMPROBABLE GOALS.
WE AT THE UC SYSTEM DO NOT WANT
FOR INNOVATIVE THINKING OR
QUALITY ADMINISTRATION.
THE FAILURE TO PLACE LET THE
NASCENT LATINOS INTO
ADMINISTRATIVE IN FACT THE RANKS
IS A LACK OF COMMITMENT NOT
CAPACITY.
IF WE CAN'T DO IT IS NOT BECAUSE
IT'S HARD BUT WE CAN BECAUSE WE
YOU SEE JUST DO NOT CARE ENOUGH.
MY MASTER MY PAST EXPERIENCE
LEAD ME TO PROTECT THAT IN
ANOTHER TEN YEARS FROM NOW
ANOTHER GROUP LIKE THIS WILL
MEET AS WE ARE TODAY.
AND HERE SIMILAR CONCERNS
LAMENTS REASONS EXCUSES PLUS
MORE GOALS AND PLANS ALL COMBINE
TO REFLECT ON SIXTY YEARS OF
UC'S LATIN X. PROBLEM.
THANK YOU.
TIME IS UP THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN DEALER
DOORS DAVISON PRESIDENT VICE
PRESIDENT NOT PRESENT YET OF THE
ACADEMIC SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES --
AND I WELL I NORMALLY DO NOT
STATE MY FILIATION FOR MY
COLLEGE I AM A PROUD PROFESSOR
OF HISTORY AND GENDER STUDIES AT
FOOTHILL COLLEGE SO.
MY PRESIDENT IS RIGHT THERE --
SO I HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING AS A
GRADUATE OF UC DAVIS FROM A A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO I'VE BEEN
REFLECTING ON HOW MANY FEMALE.
FACULTY I HAD AND I CAN SAY THAT
THERE ENTIRE TIME I WAS THERE --
HOWEVER I WILL SAY THAT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF OREGON AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF ILLINOIS AHEAD
NONE SO IT LEASE WE HAVE --
ONE WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD VERY
MUCH TO CONTINUING THESE
HEARINGS ABOUT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND THE SEA ISSUES.
AND TO TALKING TO YOU ABOUT THE
DIVERSIFICATION EFFORTS THAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
UNDERTAKING --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN ADDITION
FOR THE FUNDING THAT YOU
PROVIDED --
WE LOOK FORWARD TO TRYING TO IT
TRYING TO DO A LOT WITH THAT IN
THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS.
AND WE WANTED TO INVITE YOU
SINCE WE'RE DOWN IRVINE NEXT
WEEK IF YOU'RE AROUND FEASIBLE
JUST COME ON BY OUR PLENARY
SESSION YOU DON'T EVEN NEED A
BADGE WILL JUST LET YOU IN.
SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN DEANNA
CATHERINE NELSON CHAIR OF THE
ACADEMIC SENATE CSU ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT --
TO DIVERSITY IN FACULTY HIRING
HOLDING THESE HEARINGS.
AND HOLDING THE FEET OF THE FIVE
THREE SEGMENTS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION CALIFORNIA TO THE FIRE
ON THIS ISSUE.
I ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS A FACULTY
DIVERSITY HIGH AT THE CSU AND
LOOK FOR TO THAT SESSION IN THE
COMING YEAR THANK YOU PROUD
GRADUATE OF UC SANTA CRUZ AND UC
DAVIS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO SEVEN LEYVA JOSE MEDINA
AND STAFF MY NAME IS TODD DIEGO
ERROR I SAID ON THE CAL AGGIE
ALUMNI.
BOARD AND ALSO A CO CHAIR OF THE
CHICANO LATINO UC ALUMNI
ASSOCIATION RECENTLY WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET SATURDAY.
AND UCBERKELEY WERE EIGHT OF
THE TEN UNIVERSITIES USE
UNIVERSITIES WERE IN ATTENDANCE
WE HAD ASKED THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT TO BE PRESENT.
EVEN THOUGH WE WERE ONLY A
COUPLE MILES AWAY THERE WAS NO
ONE PRESENT.
SO WE THINK THEY NEED TO BE
PRESENT.
THEY NEED TO REACH OUT ALSO --
WITH REGARD TO JUST LEADERSHIP
WE DON'T SEE OUR LEADERS.
IN THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
NOR DO WE SEE IT ON THE A LOT OF
THE CAMPUSES IN MY OWN CAMPUS OF
UC DAVIS.
WE HAVE THIRTY ONE LEADERS --
DEAN'S THEIR REPORT TO THE
CHANCELLOR OF THOSE.
THIRTY ONE NONE ARE LATINO.
THE OTHER DIRECTS TO OUR
CHANCELLOR.
AND ONLY ONE óRDENES SO WE HAVE
A LONG WAYS TO GO AND THE ONLY
WAY WE'RE GONNA GET THERE IS BY
RESULTS.
AND HOLDING PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE I
HEARD --
PROVOST WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
THAT HE WAS GOING TO GO DOWN TO
THE LEADERSHIP CONFERENCE TO
HEAR I I WOULD I WOULD VENTURE
TO SAY THAT YOU SHOULD GO DOWN
TO TELL US.
WHAT YOUR ROLE IS AND THE
INITIATIVES AT THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENTARE GOING TO DO TO
INCREASE DIVERSITY AND FACULTY
THANK YOU HOPE TO MEET WITH YOU
SEE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHEN IS THAT IS --
JOSE MAYOR M. WHICH AS IT SS
AGAIN FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING
AND ALSO FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THIS AREA --
I'M MY NAME'S LOOK BACK IDEA
GOES THE S. I'VE BEEN AT UC
BERKELEY FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS A
STAFF AND THIRTY TWO WITH MY
GRADUATE YEARS.
AND I JUST WANTED TO MENTION
THREE THINGS SOMEONE WHO HAS
BEEN A STUDENT STAFF NOW AN
ADMINISTRATOR. TO ALSO THINK
ABOUT WHAT ARE WE DOING FOR
STAFF DEVELOPMENT IN REGARDING
TO ADMINISTRATIVE POSITIONS AND
WHAT ARE WE CREATING AROUND THAT
BUT NOT ONLY ON SPECIFIC
CAMPUSES BUT IT WITHIN THE UC.
THE OTHER ONE I ALSO WANT TO
MENTION IS TO ACTUALLY THINK
ABOUT THOSE PROGRAMS THAT WERE
FUNDED BY THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT FROM DOCUMENTS
STUDENTS SOME SOME OF THOSE
FUNDS NOT RE OCCURRING.
ON OUR CAMPUS SOMEBODY WENT ON
YOUR FIRE BALL WHICH IS ACTUALLY
PRODUCING SCHOLARS TO BECOME PH
DIS.
IS RIGHT NOW WITH --
THEY'RE THINKING ABOUT NOT
REFUNDING LIFTED BOTH NOT ON OUR
CAMPUS BUT ACROSS THE CAMPUS
SPECIFICALLY THOSE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY PRODUCING PHD RESEARCH
STUDENTS OF COLOR PARTICULARLY
LATINOS AND IN THE STEM.
AND THE LAST ONE IS ALSO TO
THINK ABOUT AS WE'RE GOING
THROUGH THESE KIND OF RETHINKING
RESHAPING RE INSTITUTIONALIZING
YOUR AND CREATING
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE IS ALSO
TO THINK ABOUT THE CLASS ISSUES
IN REGARDS TO ACCESS --
SOME OF THE IMPACTS THAT ARE
HAPPENING ACROSS ACADEMIC
CHANGES WITH THE CALENDAR AND
THE IMPACTS FOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WHO CAN'T HAVE ACCESS
PARTICULARLY AROUND.
ORIENTATIONS WHEN OUR DURING THE
WEEK VERSES ON THE WEEKENDS AND
WE'VE BEEN BRINGING THESE ISSUES
UP AND I JUST WANTED TO PUT
THOSE OUT THERE FOR TODAY AND
THANK YOU FOR THIS AGAIN.
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN CAROLINE COULD BE IS --
THANK YOU FOR ASKING THE
QUESTION OF HOW LONG AND WHAT IT
WILL TAKE --
TO FAIRLY OPEN THE DOORS OF YOU
SEE TO WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THIS ISN'T A HEARING ON FACULTY
UNDER REPRESENTATION HOWEVER I
WANT TO GIVE YOU A VERY RECENT
EXAMPLE OF INSTITUTIONAL
PRACTICES THAT MUST BE CHANGED
IF REAL PROGRESS IS TO BE MADE
IN THE UC SYSTEM.
A RECENT ASSOCIATE VICE
CHANCELLOR POSITION WAS FILLED
WITH A WHITE MALE AND A LATINO
CANDIDATE WAS NOT GIVEN
CONSIDERATION.
THE POSITION PAYS AROUND A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND A
YEAR.
IT REPORTS TO THE VICE
CHANCELLOR WHO REPORTS THE
CHANCELLOR THAT'S A FAIRLY HIGH
LEVEL OF MANAGEMENT YOU WOULD
THINK -- I
WAS TOLD THAT THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE POSITION AT THIS VERY
HIGH LEVEL WAS A TECHNICAL
GROUNDING NOT MANAGEMENT
EXPERIENCE.
YOU CAN SEE WHERE THIS IS GOING
TO LEAD YOU HAVE TO HAVE BEEN A
BABY TO BE HIRED AND WORKED
FORTY YEARS TO EVER POSSIBLY
REACH THAT EXECUTIVE LEVEL
MANAGEMENT POSITION.
MOREOVER THIS REQUIREMENT
APPEARS ARBITRARY AND PROBABLY
HAS NOT BEEN VALIDATED AS AN HR
BEST PRACTICE.
YOU SEE MUST BE DIRECTED TO
ADDRESS IT INSTITUTIONAL
PRACTICES SUCH AS THIS DIRECTLY
IF CHANGES EVER TO BE MADE IN
THE UC SYSTEM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR HEARING FROM MAY
ARTHUR HERNANDEZ I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AND THE FAMILY
NURSE PRACTITIONER.
ALSO THE ELEVENTH IN A FAMILY
FIFTEEN FORMER MIGRANT FARM
WORKERS I AM --
UC DAVIS GRADUATE ALSO GRADUATE
THE CSU SYSTEM AND THE CLERK --
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM HOW
AFTER FRANCISCO NODS HIS POINT
HERE LEGISLATE CONTINUE HE LEFT
OFF WE'RE REFLECTING ON TEN
ADDITIONAL YEARS OF THE UC DIS
LET NEXT.
A SITUATION AND MAYBE AND IT
LOOKING FORWARD HE SAID I LOOKED
TO MY ESTEEM UC COLLEAGUES TO
PROVE MY PREDICTION WRONG THE
NEXT TEST FOR YOU SEE WILL BE
THE CHANCELLOR BACK VACANCY UC
SANTA CRUZ.
A HISPANIC SERVING INSTITUTION
WITH A LATIN ACCEPT MOMENT
EXCEEDING 35% I LOOK TO MY UC
COLLEAGUES TO TAKE BOLD AND
DECISIVE ACTION TODAY.
THAT WILL LAUNCH A MAJOR CHANGE
EFFORT ON BEHALF OF LATIN
COMMUNITY AND I WOULD THEIR SAID
THE CALIFORNIA.
COMMUNITY NOT JUST THAT I THINK
WE'RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER RIGHT --
SO THAT IN TEN YEARS OTHERS WILL
LOOK BACK ON THIS MEETING IS A
TURNING POINT EACH OF US CAN SAY
EACH OF YOU CAN SAY.
AND RESPOND I KNOW I WAS THERE I
WOULD SAY AND I WOULD SAY FOR
MYSELF --
I'VE BEEN AT UC DAVIS HEALTH FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS SEVENTEEN YEARS
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU --
I'M PROUD TO BE AN AGGIE I'M
PROUD TO SEE THE CHANGES
HAPPENING ARE BUT THEY'RE NOT
HAPPENING QUICKLY ENOUGH.
BECAUSE I LOOK BACK AND THE
CONSEQUENCES OF INACTION HAS LED
I BELIEVE HOURS GOVERNMENT
SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT. TO TEETER
AT TIMES AND WE'RE NOW FACING
SOME OF THE SAME FIGHTS THAT WE
FOUGHT FIFTY YEARS AGO.
IN A DIFFERENT WAY NEW WAYS BUT
I THINK IT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME
BOLD COURAGEOUS ACTION ON THE
PART OF LEADERSHIP.
AT ALL LEVELS AND I WOULD SAY
[inaudible]
THAT INCLUSIVE EXCELLENCE
MATTERS.
EVERYWHERE TALKING ABOUT HOW WE
NEED.
TO PROMOTE.
PEOPLE WHO WERE BORN AND RAISED
IN CALIFORNIA GOT THEIR PH DIS
IN CALIFORNIA.
RIGHT AS WELL AS OTHER PLACES
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REFLECT OUR LEADERSHIP TO ASK
OUR LEADERSHIP TO BE PERSISTENT
AND CONSISTENT.
IN MESSAGING THE NEED FOR
DIVERSITY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
AYE AYE I WANNA SAY THAT --
THE TIMER EURO WAS NOT AN
INDICATION OF WHO OR WHAT I
AGREE WITH AS A MATTER OF FACT --
THERE IS MUCH SAID IN THIS
HEARING --
AND AND AND I THINK THE MOST OF
THE FOLKS IN THIS ROOM TODAY AT
THIS HEARING.
AGREE AND I AGREE WITH THE
STATEMENT THAT I HEARD HERE IN
IN -- PUBLIC
STATEMENT THAT I ALSO HEARD TWO
YEARS AGO AT SAN JOSE STATE AND
I THINK IT IS WORTH REPEATING MY
REPEATED --
BUT MAYBE.
FIRST A SHORT STORY.
THIS WEEKEND UC RIVERSIDE GAVE
ITS ALUMNI METAL. TWO CHARLES
YOUNG.
CHANCELLOR CHARLES YOUNG OF UCLA
WHO.
MYSELF INCLUDED PROBABLY.
MANY PEOPLE DON'T KNOW HE WAS A
GRADUATE OF UC RIVERSIDE.
MATTER FACT HE WAS THE FIRST
STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT AT UC
RIVERSIDE.
BELIEVE IT WAS NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
YOU SEE FIRSTHAND BODY PRESIDENT
CHARLES E. YOUNG.
THEN PROFESSOR THEN CHANCELLOR
AT UC RIVERSIDE.
AND HIS CHANCE --
YOUNG SPOKE AT YOU RECEIVING HIS
METAL.
DISTINGUISHED ALUMNI HE
MENTIONED THAT THE ONE OF THE
BIGGEST THINGS THAT HE AS
CHANCELLOR.
WAS PROUD OF WAS HOW HIS EFFORT
TO DIVERSIFY THE STUDENT BODY AT
UCLA.
FROM THE EARLY NINETEEN SIXTIES
ON AND I AGREE WITH THE
STATEMENT THEN THAT I HEARD HERE
THAT I ALSO HEARD.
AT SAN JOSE STATE TWO YEARS AGO
AND THAT STATEMENT CAME FROM
THEN FACULTY AT UC BERKELEY --
AFRICAN AMERICAN A BELIEVE
ASTRONOMER WHO SAID.
WHAT I HEARD HERE AND PUBLIC'S
THAT STATEMENT THAT UC CAN DO?
WHAT IT WANTS TO DO?
THAT IT HAS THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT.
I AGREE WITH BOTH OF THE
GENTLEMEN WHO SAID THAT.
AT SAN JOSE STATE AND SAID IT
HERE.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT IT IS A
COMMITMENT NOT ONLY.
AND HERE YOU KNOW I I I I AGAIN
MY SOMEWHAT FRUSTRATION.
AS AT AGE SIXTY FIVE HEARING IS
NOT ENOUGH FOR ME.
I CAN NO LONGER JUST LISTEN TO
GOOD.
WILL.
OR EVEN ATTEMPTS.
I DO LIKE MY A COLLIE KEVIN
MCCARTY WANT TO SEE RESULTS.
WANT TO SEE RESULTS BECAUSE WE
DO NOT WANNA BE BACK HERE. TEN
YEARS FROM NOW TWENTY YEARS FROM
NOW HAVING THE SAME DISCUSSION --
UC RIVERSIDE IS ALSO BEEN THE
HOME TO THE ONLY TWO LATINO
CHANCELLORS.
IN THE UC SYSTEM IN ITS HISTORY
[inaudible]
FIRST.
THE MASS RIVERA.
WHO WAS CHANCELLOR WHEN I GOT MY
MASTERS IN? NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT UC RIVERSIDE.
AND THEN [inaudible]
OF COURSE.
FRANCE'S CORDOVA WHO CAME LATER
TO LATINO CHANCELLORS IN THE
HISTORY OF YOU SEE.
THE LAST BEING THE FIRST FRANCES
CORDOVA BEING THE SECOND.
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY
[inaudible]
MOVING FORWARD. TO HAVE.
A THIRD CHANCER THERE IS NONE OF
THE TEN CAMPUSES IS THERE A LET
THE NO.
CHANCE FOR AT THIS TIME I THINK
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY AT UC
SANTA CRUZ.
AND TO ME IT WOULD BE.
IT IS NOT ALL.
IT IS CERTAINLY NOT ALL AND THIS
WON'T SOLVE THE PROBLEM OR
NEITHER IS IT IMPORTANT JUST TO
HAVE.
FIGURES BUT IT IS TO ME
UNACCEPTABLE.
THAT OUT OF TEN CHANCELLOR'S AS
I GO TO THE REGENTS MEETING
THERE IS NOT ONE CHANCELLOR
THERE WHO COMES FROM THE LATINO
COMMUNITY.
I THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY I HOPE IT'S
BEEN VALUABLE AND I HOPE THAT WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH THESE
DISCUSSIONS.
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
ROGER